Mainframe. We hack in the mainframe on this one we plan.
No, it better be puking. One second late. No.
No one's puking. Sorry about what we'll select around. I was on- I was on the wrong world.
Okay, hold on. Let me be bad. Let me be a bad streamer.
It's going to chat. I need to say world is 3-8-8.
And we edge in and edge in.
Did I mention how much I dislike vowels and words? It makes spelling things impossible.
Absolutely impossible.
Oh no, no, no. No vomit. I'm here. No vomit. Good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon.
I'm sorry if I sound like the sleepiest little sleepy head that ever did sleep.
You'll never guess why. It's because I'm a sleepy head.
Shock and behavior, I know.
Yeah, good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon. How are you?
I was just watching your latest collab video with none other than Iciclesnopauseus.
That is her full legal name. Iciclesnopauseus.
It's not. I just made that up. Her name is Iciclesnopauseus.
I don't know why I did that. What would-
I mean, if you wanted to shut up in me and make her nervous.
You know, like when your parents say your full legal name and you know you're in trouble?
Emmys is emo- emo-to-bizu, I guess.
It's time. I'm getting the skill-cape. Yes, so just to give a very quick recap.
For those of you who haven't really kept up the series, no, I'm not insulted.
It's literally hours upon hours of ranting gameplay, watch longs, all that jazz.
We are new friends.
We're about to hit nine to eight. We have 6,000 wines to go, which is absolutely nothing
compared to what on earth we've- what should I name again? Jimmy-bizu.
Right. I see Jimmy one more time. Ah, sorry. I named- I couldn't have named Emmy more perfect.
I don't care what anyone says. I couldn't have named her more perfect, okay?
I've been- I've been kicked off the development team in the naming department.
So, unfortunately, we're not gonna have another fondle of bosom.
And that is- that is the fate, okay? You can't restart. That path has- that path has been- it's been happening, okay?
She hates when Pimpel says Emmy-bizu from Veal or Generation One and Doll to her full legal name.
Just her government-ish name.
Emm...
Emm- Emmy-bizu. Ah, sorry, it's bizu.
Eh, en français? Mh? Bizu, monsieur. Bizu pas moi?
Just means kiss. There's none really to it.
But yes, if your bidi-little eyes, my darling wreathling is able to see,
em, I have 6,800 wines to go,
which, in theory- there you go, 6,800.
In theory, if I balls to the walls, this will take us to the four-hour mark.
Are you squiddling me right now?
Let Mummy name the children.
Mama, you're in the wrong world. We can't find you.
Shit, where am I?
Wait, am I not in the right-
Oh no! I need to be in 380. Hold on, I'm swapping to 380.
I'm doing- fuck it, we're doing it live.
Yes, I want to switch to World 380. What the heck? I want my wreathling.
Sorry.
But yes, eh, today I- oh, there's my wreathling.
There we go. Okay, much better, much better.
Is there vomit on the floor? No, we're safe. There's no cabbage on the floor, okay.
It's my wreathling.
You're more than welcome to chill out.
But yes, it has been a childhood little goal of mine to get a skill cape,
and we- like, we're doing it today.
Like, there's no way we're not getting it done today.
Now, I know originally today we're supposed to be the-
the-
the what?
It was supposed to be the information stream type thingy, my Bobber.
I needed time to prepare because I did a lot of background work.
Management told me there was quite a few clippers that applied to the program.
We're really happy.
Oh, we actually made the VTuber news.
Oh, Christmas miracle.
So obviously it got a bit of a boost, which was really nice.
We got, like, a lot of compliments as well.
Like, I saw the response to the clipping program being launched,
and there's lots of nice comments attached to people being very kind,
saying, you know what, that's the fairest I've seen yet.
That's this, that's this.
And I'm glad, like, that's what I want.
I want, you know, the people that do get accepted into the clipping program,
you know, I want them to be like, yeah, I'm getting a fair price for what's going on.
And, you know, I don't feel like resentful making these clips or anything,
because obviously the more love and appreciation that goes into a clip,
the more, you know, it translates through and blandering, blandering,
it's a strong old-school runescape felt.
I played this game multiple times in my childhood,
but what would happen is I would get to level 40 in a skill,
and then I would get disinterested.
So, on debut, I said, you know what?
I'm gonna put it down and write in.
I want a runescape cake before I, like, before, you know, wrap it up, okay?
I'm not wrapping it up in English, okay?
Okay, I'm strutting a couple of buns very soon.
And if you are on my alt-twitter, I, I, this sounds so silly.
I know I can repeat myself a little bit.
Do apologize. Do apologize. I repeat myself.
I have been able to blast through stupendous amounts of work,
because it, like, it takes a while for things to click in my head.
And that's fine. I'm slow. I can admit it.
And it clicked that if I blast through my work this week,
I can go straight back to the fun stuff.
And I'm starting to feel the stress lifting off of my shoulders.
And, like, we've got the third editor in play, like, just everything.
It's coming together. You know how every day I come on, like,
oh, oh, soon, soon, I don't have to do it.
Soon, soon, I literally do not control, do anything.
It's all done by everyone else.
Soon, it's happening.
The pieces are falling together.
The stress is lifting off my shoulders.
I can start to feel, I can get a boner again.
Like, I'm starting to feel like that.
And I'm getting so excited.
Like, I was on my other, my alt-twitter.
And there is this artwork that I adore.
And originally it was supposed to be for something,
but I couldn't stop myself.
I wanted to post it because it's a little rare friend.
And another life when we played Elden Ring together,
I got wrecked, okay?
I got wrecked and decked, okay?
And it was by a lance enemy.
And it was one thrust of a lance, and I died.
So then I said the phrase,
one thrust was all it took.
And then did I go to an artist and get that commissioned?
Yes, I did.
Shamelessly, I got that commissioned.
I don't care.
Sorry, I don't care if it's shameless.
One thrust was all it took from my little reefling, okay?
The one thrust.
Trying to get a bone bone again.
Good that you're starting to relax and get less work too.
Yes, like, the transitional period of handing over work
to other people is difficult in terms of,
they wouldn't do it my way,
but my way isn't the right way.
And that's just a fact.
My way is not the right way.
So I need to get that out of my head right away,
because, you know, like, I got a Marshmallow,
and they were like, I really like AC's new ASMR video,
but it's very new coded.
And I said, you know, that's perfectly,
well, I didn't say anything
because, well, we don't reply to Marshmallows,
but I was like, yes.
So AC's newest ASMR role play, check it out.
Check out the link in the description below.
I wrote that to get her back into ASMR,
and she said that she's really happy
to do her improv ASMR.
Because if you didn't know,
AC is an incredibly creative being,
and she can, I don't know how she does this.
I have never been more jealous
of a cute little adorable polar bear.
She can do that.
I don't know.
She's an adorable, adorable polar bear.
She can make ASMR off the top of her head.
Like, what?
You don't have to sit down for an hour
and write a script and, you know,
and then off the top of her head improv?
What? What?
Do you know how much money?
Do you know how many generations,
how many times I would get pregnant
by the reeflings if I had this ability?
It'd be over for your tentacle.
You'd be milk dry.
You'd be speaking of being milk dry.
Hold on a minute.
Speaking of being milk dry,
check what I saw on Twitter.
Check it.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, my OBS just crashed.
Don't do that again.
Like what I found on Twitter before I booted up.
Speaking of being milk dry,
give me my gender right now.
I got this on Twitter.
Thank you very much.
You know who you are.
I'm going to make this my schedule post
for next week because I love it so much.
Look at your wee withered tentacles as well.
They're all withered.
Have pressure.
Get that guy a glass of water.
You're going to need more than water
to replenish what I oink off.
The V-sucky allegations are true.
We're actually just all succubus.
Thank you again, tiny spiny.
I'm so sorry if I didn't say your name.
I'm very all over the place recently.
Literally, real one.
Mummy, the spirit is willing,
but the tentacle is withered and sore
of my babies.
Lots of water and tomatoes, honestly.
Maui babies.
Kapiti.
Tomorrow's going to be the education stream
and then I'm going to come back online
because I'm going to be bing-ching
d'ajuma with my
friend, Arissa.
It will be the first time we have
interacted with each other,
which I adore.
I find adorable.
Tomatoes?
Yes, tomatoes replenish your prostate.
There's no other way to say it.
Look after it, you're going to need it
when you're at the milking farm.
I can't believe you posted...
I can't believe you posted to your
Patreon even though you put a mental
chastity bell on us.
I mean, I'm not going to be mad
if you cheat-sy-doodle
because I do need...
I think
tomorrow or the day after
the 20K celebration photos
will be made.
It's either...
No, not today, tomorrow.
Tomorrow or the day after.
I'm losing it.
Does ketchup count?
It does count because it contains
the compound.
I think it's like a lisonin or something
like that, which is exactly
what they're wanting.
You needed one day to get over the
stress of work, so glad it worked.
We're ready for you.
Fill your agenda.
Oh yeah, you want to fill my agenda,
right?
There's some compound in a tomato
cup that begins with L
and it's what's really good for you.
Lysopenia?
I don't know.
Not only the agenda.
Thank you.
Agenda?
I don't know where I was going with
that. I'm a mechanic.
What gender are you?
I'm a beach driver.
Have you seen that meme?
You must stop.
You must stop because like, oh, what
gender are you?
I'm a mechanic.
It's literally me.
Agendinate my balls.
Agenda, germinate.
When I see it start growing,
it's called germination.
I'm sure there's some sort of
joke in here.
I'm doing it.
Okay, let me drink my tea before I
drink it.
I'm sorry.
Estrani Carl's got to be one of
my favorite genders.
Thank you. Thank you, Nori.
You didn't know Nori's actually
really big on old school runescape,
so if you like the grind with the
grind while someone grinds,
everyone grind in live, then
definitely check out Nori as well
because she is grinding that
old school runescape.
If you're into ginger and stream,
check out Nori.
If not,
you should still check out Nori.
You never know.
You may just, you may fanger.
Kami oshi.
Kami oshi de.
Oh my God, I'm not.
I'm not Min Maxon.
Just got back from home.
How far away are we now?
6,000 wanes.
Now, if my maths is correct,
in three hours time,
I will officially
have the look of the drip
on this reflim.
See that drip?
See these shoulder pads?
See that red outline?
See the pot?
Look at the little steam
coming off that pot.
Oh, oh, oh, he's hitting us
with the skillet.
Oh, oh, oh,
that's right.
He fucking flipped that T-bone.
That's right.
You show him how it is.
Oh, he put the freaking,
it's a meat pie.
It's a meat pie.
Oh my God.
He just hit us with a meat pie.
And we just got 98.
Well, it's getting rised by a
reflim.
Actually got rised so hard there.
But we're at 98.
The progress is nice.
We need nai,
but a million XP,
which in theory is 6,000 wanes,
I guess.
Is that right?
Is that the maths right?
It's so big.
It is.
Also,
another reflim
that's already done it.
And he's doing wanes
in solidarity with me.
No, you cannot help me,
but thank you for your kindness.
I'm beyond help.
Oh my God.
Look at the hairstyle.
The four, like,
four, like, little,
I don't know what you called them,
a little too random.
What's it called on dinosaurs
when they have, like,
a little extra platelet
on the back of their head?
That's what that hairstyle
reminds me of,
but I'm sure
there's, like,
an actual thing.
Still have
the
what in the little wane.
5,000 equals a million?
I can fix that.
No, I can.
Only 69, 69 left.
Wait, am I under?
Am I under?
Do I need more?
More, though?
Or did I misunderstand the communication?
Are you trolling?
Because I'll believe you.
69, 69 left.
I'll believe you.
I'll murder you.
Are you telling the truth
that I misunderstand?
Do I need more?
I'm down under there, you.
I can make her worse.
I believe the term is called scuttle.
I made fan art
for the first time ever
by hand on you on Twitter.
It's not like,
oh my God, let's check it out.
Did you at me?
The Twitter notifications
are rubbish.
I swear, if it's,
if it's the other,
if it's small fish,
not sure I can show it off.
Hold on.
Did you at me?
I don't think you did,
because that's okay,
because you don't have to,
because I will look for it
myself manually.
Small fish,
and we'll look at stone art.
Oh God, I need a min-max.
Sorry.
Escape.
Combine.
Space.
Where's the small fish?
I don't see it.
Wait, what?
What is this?
No, it wasn't the AI one.
This is the AI one?
I've just thought,
I've just discovered
there's an AI one of me.
God damn,
how many folds does my kitschy got?
Get that AI out of here.
Yeah,
if it was the AI one,
it actually does look like me.
AI gets scarily good.
There's like three folds
on the kitsch.
I'm like, all right,
but I still got my hypnosis symbol.
What the fuck?
AI is getting so good,
like scarily good.
How did you tell it
to put the detail of my tape on?
That's crazy.
It's nice to see you.
It's nice to see you too.
Get it?
Because like the ocean and the sea.
Okay, okay.
And that was it.
I need to give it a cheeky like.
As I said,
I don't mind AI art.
It's not,
it's not really a big deal to me.
If you want to put me in a wheelchair next to me,
because of my heart condition,
then by all means,
just understand that
AI art,
I won't use in a schedule
or a YouTube thumbnail
for an ASMR role play,
for example,
that's not me.
I don't want to monetize it.
If you want to,
I don't want to.
I did it by hand and attitude.
Wait,
I'm strong.
Bro, both of us,
I'm in the mind chef looking from,
well,
you're in the mind chef
looking for diamonds.
I'm in the mind chef.
You know,
see, this is what I don't like about Twitter.
It is so busted right now.
I can't see a thing.
I can't see a single thing.
No one is at me.
I wonder,
is your account new on Twitter?
Because it hides stuff.
It makes it like impossible to find.
Don't finish those lyrics.
I've finished them enough, honestly.
How is Min Maxson for 99 going?
Considering we're 98,
we've fled.
I think we're doing pretty dang good.
I'm the diamond.
Aww.
Thank you.
No,
I'm the pearlescent.
Even though there's not pearlescent,
I'm pearlescent, okay.
Nice journey, sorry.
I'm like, no, don't be silly.
You go to Guba.
We just get in beachy.
Right.
Give me this fucking Twitter.
I swear to God,
if it's just not anything.
Good.
Why does that not show up?
I see it.
Oh my God.
Wait, hold on.
I need to make sure,
I need to make sure I can show it on screen.
Okay, hold on a minute.
Hold on a minute.
We need,
hold on, I need Min Maxson.
We're already at 6.2.
We started on 6.8.
Right, hold on.
Where is she?
This is safe to show on screen.
Hold on, let me put it on.
Actually, maybe I should do that,
like a fan art.
Oops.
That's my PC.
Don't worry.
That's me.
That's not your PC.
That was my PC.
It's having a hard time, okay.
Are you ready?
Boom.
It's me.
Oh my God.
Look, you can see my full model,
but you don't get to see my actual full model.
I'm dead.
Look at me and I got my tape.
I got my spare.
Oh wait, you can't see my mouse cursor.
Dang it.
I don't have anything to mouse cursor we're over with.
Look, you got my yukata.
You got my tape and you got everything.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I definitely need to go and show off all the fan art stream
and I just get to like, oh my God.
Even has the butt fangs.
Honestly.
I was going to make, so I can't believe it.
Reflings.
How far I've fallen.
So obviously I want the girls to be as successful and popular.
So me and AC have devised the plan.
And on one day in this month, she's going to take my time slot.
I'm going to take her time slot.
I'm going to do a smart redirect into her.
Because I want the most success for everyone.
Me and AC came up with a plan.
So devious.
Oh, it's so devious.
One stream I swapped my stream.
That's it.
That's literally the plan.
But obviously when I retweet the girls and all that,
I want them to be shown off as much as possible.
So you don't have VTubers just screen cap themselves
for like five seconds doing something cute.
I was going to be a cheeky sod and screen capture my thighs
and be like, did you know that I had butt fangs
but you never see it?
Because obviously you stream from the face up
and nothing else.
A truly nefarious.
What?
Here's the plan.
We get to be other girls more sometimes.
Literally I'm like,
Datel management for the clipper program
to not clip me and focus on clipping the girls.
Because I want the girls to succeed.
I have everything I want right now and so much more.
I have my reef flings.
I have all the goofy plots we're going to do.
I have all the audios that we're going to make together.
Like I'm sending off the blue site information
to get that prepared.
Because I would like to try one stream on it
and see how it goes.
And if we like it, we like it.
If we don't like it, maybe it's going to...
Definitely a once in a blue moon type thing.
It's not my...
Oh my God.
A reef language is to trade with me.
What are you going to offer me?
It better not be a crusty sock.
It's a crusty sock, isn't it?
Be honest.
It's a crusty sock.
I'm going to drink my tea.
Oh, are you harvesting me?
Because I'm a diamond?
Because you're in the main shaft looking for diamonds?
Oh, reef land.
That's so sweet.
I got a pickaxe.
Thank you.
Here you go.
I'll give you gloves in exchange.
Let's trade.
I had to accept trade.
Fuck you.
We're trading again.
You need to protect your hands when you touch the bean.
Okay?
Because it's super sensitive.
That's not even...
I didn't even try and hide it.
The diamond.
Okay?
The diamond sensitive to the touch.
Put some gloves on.
Okay?
It's too sensitive.
You need...
Here, take these.
Take these.
You need them.
Yes, you need them.
Take them.
There.
Nice and secure.
Okay, let's...
Let's get to...
We're already about to hit the 5K.
That's funny.
I'm in the same cave looking for...
I'm gonna go spelunking.
Literally, like, I'm so excited.
I don't know if I said this.
Empire inspired me to purchase a ice block maker for the freezer.
And I literally have it right now.
Here, listen.
Listen.
Oh, if I can reach it.
Hold on.
Okay, that was...
That was my loop.
Hear that?
That is a silicon.
Oh, it's just split apart.
Wait, I did it.
I got the silicon.
Okay.
So, some nefarious things are happening soon to you.
I've got all the plans, all the things.
I just need to cook.
I have technically done one of the three major things that I need to do.
Okay?
In the background.
I don't have membership, but I don't need membership anymore.
Because I didn't realise winemaking was free and all that jazz.
So, I bought membership, but I didn't need it.
But we'll definitely come back to RuneScape and do some missions together.
Is the ice gonna be a thing?
I don't know.
Let's sign this.
You need membership to claim this cape.
Oh, for fuck's sake!
Are you serious?
You can't claim the cape without paying membership?
Is that real?
Oh my god.
Hook, line and sinker?
What?
I didn't know.
It also costs 99 to buy.
Okay.
The good thing is I've got the moola thanks to the reeflings.
Supplying me with like 20 million.
We can give you the gold easy.
I actually do have, I have 29 million gold.
Did I earn a penny of that?
Absolutely not.
Do girl gamers have it easier?
Well, the stream definitely sways the perception that yes, vitriol is a ripple.
They got us over the barrel.
I've been bamboozled.
Yeah, I didn't know that.
She's fixing a window with a silicone, clearly.
I just need my cock on the window.
And then I get a spackle and spank it down.
Wait, I'm getting treated.
Hold on.
I am shred, not to be confused with Shrek the hit TV series.
What would you like to offer?
What is this?
It's a necklace.
What is it though?
This strength amulet?
What do...
Am I going to be supposed to walk?
Bunk.
Ooh.
Oh, it's a sword hindle thingy, my bobber.
I've forgotten what they're called.
Oh my god.
Check the drip.
Check it through the bank booth.
Check the drip through the bank.
Check.
Oh, there we go.
Let's get a little...
Let's get a little refling on the shoulder.
Bonds are $14.6 million.
Well, I have enough in-game currency to buy a bond,
so I'm going to use my...
Ooh, how did I...
I don't know how I messed that up so successfully,
but I did, and that's okay.
Are you a professional colt squeezer?
You're just going to have to come over here and find that.
Yeah, don't spend any real money if you can help her.
I appreciate you, like, my very conscious of her,
and I hate her.
Just draw because what you find fun is fun, you know?
Like, I...
I can't draw.
You should pop...
You should check out my Gen 2,
draw Gen 2 suggestion streams.
I have no drawing background.
I was just goofing off.
You know what?
You're not going to be Picasso off the bat.
People that...
You know, artists like Emmy, for example.
Emmy didn't spawn out of the womb like that.
You know, she's put years and years behind it.
Don't kick yourself down.
Pick yourself up type thing, you know?
Don't be the one who's harsh to yourself.
You know, the world is already negative enough.
Don't let yourself add to that.
Don't continue the dog pile, okay?
Lift yourself up.
Be like, fuck yeah, I fucking did that.
I actually put my mind to it and did it,
because drawing is quite a big mental exercise.
It's not, you know, it's imaginative.
It's, you know, abstract concepts, all that kind of jazz.
Like, it takes time.
You're just spawning.
You can draw anime by the age of four, you know?
Is that cat day?
Oh my God, I can't believe we don't have a neck or a beech ever.
Remember that time when Veeler was doing marketing
that we purposely put A.C. when neck or ears is one of the outlines
so people thought...
So people thought we had a necko.
Ah, oh my God, I was literally getting dealt with
cloudfish in the forest, in Fangar forest.
It was so fun.
Sorry, scrawny, that I leaked the name of Gen 4.
You know what?
Discord kitten for Gen 4.
She has to be Belgian though.
I need me a Belgian beech ever.
I need her to be like, hello in German.
And then she speaks a lot of French on the say,
Bonjour, and then just the top off.
Sprinkle of, you know, Flanders type chai, you know?
I know we've got English on top.
I need my Belgian kitten.
Oh my God, I'm going to mum.
Oh, no, you can't say that out loud.
5,000, let's go.
We're already on 5,000.
Bro, steam rolling this.
Steam rolling.
I need a Falmer V-shrieber, absolutely.
What if Jimmy came out with a giant paintbrush and an easel?
Jimmy already did.
Jimmy had a drunk stream and did that.
Bonjour, Elclinc and your wagon.
Every middle European language is trying to go into a Belgium asylum
looking for future V-tubers.
You can't say that V-tubers are mentally unwell.
What are you talking about?
That is the core mechanic of being a V-tuber.
Sorry, did you spawn in perfectly fine?
Sorry, you're being denied your application.
Yep, you need to at least list three mental disorders
that you have experienced at any point in your life
before we will even take a look at your application.
Don't waste our time and don't waste your time, okay?
Let's just get into the nitty-gritty, okay?
You need a few things to go wrong in your life to be a V-tuber.
I said what I said.
And I stand by it, okay?
No, I'm healthy, it's all good.
You got it, fishman.
Gotta scuff them up a little bit.
Come on, you need some real XP before you become a V-tuber.
You gotta have some of that life experience, you know?
I hear the story about you coming against the odds.
Let's get down to business to become a virtual entertainer.
Did you...
I don't know, think it was gonna be easy.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
Awesome, ADHD, all makes sense.
Oh, you need to combine them all.
I mean, I did publicly say this, because Mercy...
Before anyone said, you're not supposed to say it,
Mercy said I'm allowed to tell the story.
So I was going through Mercy's application.
Everything looked absolutely gorgeous.
I'm very happy.
Her introduction, you know, introduced yourself video,
obviously that gives quite a high indication
of what a person is like,
because obviously they're putting their best foot forward.
So I'm reading, I'm reading, going through her application,
everything looks good.
You know, she's already come clean and said,
look, I live with my family still.
It's a bit awkward to record, but I'll make it work.
I'm like, yep, no, that's fine, you've been up front about it,
I saw good.
And then at the end of the application, it goes,
is there anything else you would like us to know?
And she goes, I've got autism.
I say, yep, you're in.
I said, you're in.
Yep.
You're in.
No questions asked.
And you come.
Gotta look after.
Gotta look after my fellow autism.
Gotta give them a chance when anyone else does.
And what did I get?
Five beautiful daughters that are fantastic.
She understood that.
Welcome to the clue.
Tism Max and the lovely Tism girls, honestly.
And you come.
I say nothing.
You're having a good time.
Don't want to stop at all.
But yeah.
No, the girls were absolutely hooting hollers
through the interview process.
Yeah, we've got a few things brewing.
A few things have been spoken into words to the girls.
I do want to say, I got a marshmallow where someone was
misunderstanding, understanding my gen two jokes
and my gen two donut on.
Right.
So let's, let's pause.
Let's empty clear your mind.
Okay.
Let's empty our minds.
So when I reference gen two, I just want to say this on the cards
right now when I mentioned gen two,
gen two is not coming in under a year.
Okay.
Of debut of gen one type thing.
That's just not a thing.
Okay.
The reason I am so open to talking about it is because
development takes an insane amount of time.
Okay.
And my donut on goals are not personal goals.
I've achieved everything I want.
I've got my refland.
I'm making the content for them.
You know, I'm saying, you know, I'm saying.
So when I talk about gen two and when I talk about my donut on
goals, I confirm the production of gen two.
Again, reminder, gen two isn't happening anytime soon.
No.
The reason I'm open to talking about it is because development
takes a very, very, very, very long time.
It took me a full year of being pregnant with Azura,
AC, ME, Mercy and Sheebie to get here.
Okay.
It took a full year.
Now, obviously when it's the first time you've ever done something
to that scale, things take time.
Hopefully it's a bit more streamlined this time.
Okay.
Wait.
Who was the time?
Also, who has the time to follow?
Six more.
It's not happening.
That's reasonable.
You can give birth every nine months.
Gen two and three hundred and six five plus one day.
No.
Bruh.
So when I say my donut on goals are related to gen two,
what I mean is that it's the confirmation of production
that we are publicly acknowledging and the models are getting ordered,
reference sheets ordered, logos ordered, loading screens ordered, music ordered.
That's what that means because it's not a thing right now.
Lower video ordered, all of that.
Everything takes a heck of amount of time.
And you know, you, as in me and the development team are relying on all these commissioners
to deliver on time when they say they're going to do it type thing as well.
That also plays a massive part.
But yes, so please don't please don't panic and be like, oh my God,
Strudy, Strudy's dropping gen one.
What the fuck?
No.
Like I tell you what it took me a year.
What?
Stop it.
You're just making stuff up to upset me.
Good morning, mummy and me.
If I ain't said herself.
If you didn't know I had a new ASMR collab role play up with Said,
I finally got to do something for myself.
Per Said.
Oh my God.
Right.
Actually, just to advertise Said for one minute.
Said is really good at whispering fast.
Now, before you like, what do you mean by that?
What I mean is that Said may or may not produce a fast whispering ASMR role play.
If you're interested in that, please feel free to check out this video.
I could not find your YouTube channel, but now that I've found it,
I will update the description because I definitely use your old fucking channel name.
So I do apologize about that.
Actually, I need to add you on Discord.
Why have I not added you on Discord?
I will send you my yield on Twitter.
Actually, you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm going to do it right now.
Fuck you.
That's right.
You're having to deal with me live stream and on Twitter.
Get right.
It's okay.
I call myself Edgy girlfriend.
Okay.
Yeah.
Like I was like linking on a link to Twitter.
No, your Twitch page because I was like, oh my God.
Wait.
We're just streamed there.
I'll have fucked that one up.
But yes, there's the second collab up.
So the next ASMR role play on my YouTube channel will be a 4,000 subscriber milestone.
Wink, wink, nudge, nudge.
But yes, I got to do an audio for myself.
I did an audio collab for the girls.
I'll just finish it off and then I'm going to attempt the second one.
And then that'll be two out of three things I had to do.
Oh my God.
You're starting on me on this.
I'm cute.
Yeah.
You're cheating.
Can we do rap?
God ASMR.
I still kept me in.
Yeah.
So Said sent me her lines.
And my dumb ass was like, uh, who said, uh, not to be a bother, but, um, you've accidentally
sped up your lines.
Do you want to know the embarrassing thing?
Um, Said didn't speed up her lines.
She's just really good at articulating while whispering fast.
And she re-recorded the line and I'm like, oh my God, I am mortified.
I am so sorry to do that to you.
ASMR role play speed running.
Well, I actually said to Said, I was like, a fast whisper in is a trigger.
Like people love it.
And for those who can participate in fast whispering like that, it's definitely a niche.
So I said they're like, you might, you might want to jump on it.
Honestly.
Um, Said to actually be an M&M.
Well, so obviously when I was editing it, so I'm like, and then I listened to Said's
and I'm like, oh no, she's forgotten to, um, she's forgotten to like less than it.
And I assumed you edited out your mistakes and just sent me whatever was left over to
Said.
And I was like, oh no, she's, she's sped up by accident.
Nope.
Turns out Said, she's just really good at whispering fast.
So don't be, don't be shy.
You might like the ASMR that comes from her channel.
Okay.
I listened to it.
Definitely sounded sped up.
However, it was not.
Okay.
I was so sorry, but that's absolutely right.
Um, she's starting to feel like a YAP God.
YAP God.
Honestly.
Um, absolutely.
Um, but yes, that was one collab.
Uh, only like 17 more go to edit.
Actually, I will say one thing though.
I do apologize to Said and for Said and a, I have been sitting on those edits for quite
some time.
But all the other collab partners that agreed to collab with me, um, are struggling to find
time to record.
And I'm like, thank the fucking maker because I do not have time to do this right now.
Um, Mercy, um, for snippets, I'm editing a Mercy Rokely.
She fucking cooked.
I sent her a really long script.
It wasn't my intention to make it a big script, but it ended up that way.
I think it's going to go down well.
So, um, I just need to cut my hair.
I was going to do it yesterday, but I got too tired.
Um, because I was up dealing with all this background stuff as always.
Um, I listened, uh, every ASMR is fast when you listen at 1.75 speed.
Can't wait.
Need my dose of Kohai.
So anyway, when she asked for more collabs and she can reasonably edit.
The thing is, once I've cleared out the schedule, then I have all the time in the world.
And as I said, I've technically done one third.
I could technically be done two thirds by the end of today.
Um, which I'm like absolutely ecstatic about.
Um, at the thought of like just the mental relief of being like, oh my God, I can like
fully dedicate myself to like editing for the girls type thing.
Um, now the third editor could do YouTube role plays and stuff.
But, I mean, I'm not opposed to it.
I suppose, like, so Mercy's newest ASMR role play, that was edited by me.
I fucking put all the sound effects that I bloody could.
I had her dropping her pen when you mentioned that, uh, you liked the teacher.
I had her scribbling on paper, moving her books.
Um, oh, sorry.
Uh, you know, I had the alarm bell go off the hallway, the walking steps, the, this or that.
Like, I really tried out my, the wazoo with them.
Um, all the time the world's strong is going to be a menace for his reef lens.
Well, that's the thing.
Like, I can kind of like swap back to my own stuff as well.
Like, I can catch up with the reef lens and catch up with my like little 100 VTuber thing.
I would really love to do the 100 VTuber collab in under a year.
Okay? In under a year.
Obviously, I'm behind in actual physical uploads.
However, to people who have agreed to collab with me, if I do 10 a month,
I am well on my way to achieving that goal, you know?
Um, yeah.
Well, you give yourself a phase.
Give me, give me a number two all over chief.
Um, so many collabs.
I love it.
Mummy has all the endurance.
What chance does reef lens have? None.
Absolutely nothing.
You have numbers.
Do you think that's enough to stop me?
Do you not remember?
My new record is a minute 30, okay?
It's over.
Absolutely over.
Um, but yes, technically, to people who have agreed to interact with me on that level,
when it comes to an ASMR collab, yes.
Um, I am aware that I give people very limited lines.
I'm going to be a cheeky shite.
Okay?
It's just this stays between just us.
I'm going to be cheeky and I'm going to write longer ASMR collabs.
Now, I actually prefer this the way I do it, where it's like five minutes of talking
and then the rest is just these tingly, foley sounds that you can just tune out.
You don't need to think, you don't need to listen,
especially for bedtime as well when you don't have to think about the tingles.
Very nice.
Um, I am going to be cheeky and try and do some more role play, some more collabs.
Now, they do take a bit more time to produce, especially script-wise,
but I'm going to try and, you know, extend the talking time for a bit longer.
Like the Denver, the Denver one was really sweet.
Um, I have a very nice collab with a VNU member in the works.
Um, she was very open and thankful and grateful.
You know, she was like, I don't want any good stuff.
And I said, no, no, no, I'm not like that.
I'm not like that.
You know, you don't need to worry.
My, my reputation precedes me in that time.
I was like, no, no, no, no, no, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's not like that.
It's okay.
She's a quick shot.
She'll even out.
Shawnee, the quickest shot in the way.
Are there any VTubers you specifically want to do a dream collab with?
Um, no.
I, I just adopt the model.
If you want to fuck with me, I'll fuck with you type shit.
Um, there's not anyone in particular where I'm like, oh my god.
Uh, I'm, I'm just happy doing that.
Um, I find the story of the Denver collab rather unsettling.
So we introduced a symbiote to you in that roleplay.
We're on 5.4.
We're already down a thousand since starting.
I wanna, uh, we're strong.
The ASMR where you talk a lot are my favorite.
Yes.
So I can obviously make myself talk, um, for as much as I want.
Like, as I said, I've actually got that community post.
If you guys don't remember, I had a community post, um, on YouTube where I asked people
to, you know, tell me what to say.
I was going to whisper it in the mic.
Um, I'm going to record that soon.
I just need to prepare all the screen shots.
Howdy.
Um, and, uh, I can record for an hour plus.
That's not a problem.
Asking a collab partner to record for an hour plus is outrageous.
Like that is entering money being offered collaboration type stuff.
So I try and reduce it to like the, it's a five minute recording experience because
it's, uh, it's kind of hard to, yeah, it's, it's hard to ask for like full commitment
because who gets the benefit of the club.
So yes, I'm the one writing it.
Yes.
I'm the one editing it.
I'm the one, um, who like has to put it together and, you know, sound effects, all that jazz.
Um, but who gets the most benefit?
Well, I do because it goes up on my channel.
I also get the money for it because I don't commission artwork.
I just use our VTuber models.
Now you could argue, well, you know, strongy, you're the, I don't know where my berries went
where my berries.
Um, now you could argue, hey strongy, but you know, you're, you're at 20,000 subscribers,
you know, it's kind of like the whole exposure thing for you exposure.
And the other person really only had to record for five minutes and that was it.
They never had to do a singular thing else because I don't need sound effects.
I don't need this.
I don't need that.
I literally have everything myself.
I just need their voice and just need them to follow the script type thing.
Um, but I am the one ultimately who benefits the most out of it.
Um, you know, it doesn't matter what size they are.
That's not really a factor.
Um, when it comes to collabs, it doesn't bother me.
I still haven't found my berries.
Um, they also get the benefit because you expose them to your members.
The more speaking lines in the cool.
Yes.
Um, exposure is kind of pointless.
Anyway, now hold on a minute.
Who said that?
Hold on a minute exposure.
What?
Exposure is why a emmer.
Wait, hold on.
You know what?
I'm going to pull it.
I'm pulling up the clip.
Smoothie Emmy.
I'm typing in smoothie Emmy.
And if it doesn't, it didn't come up.
Oh my God.
Almost quarter of them.
I literally almost quarter of a million people have seen my little sister's chest.
I'm not going to make it.
Wait, did that lag out?
Wait, I just typed the link in the chat, but it didn't pull.
Huh.
That was strange.
Did that work?
Huh.
Okay.
That worked.
That was strange.
But yeah, that obviously boosted emmer's quite a bit.
And then that obviously led to the clipping program.
Oh my God.
AC is live right now on Honeycam.
Oh, well, if you guys are not really being chilling on RuneScape, please don't worry.
AC is literally on Honeycam Studio, which is a hilarious game.
I hope she's having fun on it because it's such a good for you.
Which reminds me, I need to send away a ton of shorts because you guys have been clipping.
RuneScape at this time of day in this year, located entirely in Strony Stream.
Epic.
Exactly.
Um, we are humbly at 9 to 8.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I just realized normally I go over here.
Hi.
I'm sitting on chat.
Hi chat.
Okay, normally I go here at RuneScape just because I don't want to cover up the...
Everything.
Hi, RuneScape.
Chat Tisker.
My little RuneScape.
But it's very kind of you to worry about their comfort level.
Maybe worth asking them exposure, maybe worth a ton.
But the cost of 30 minutes is not that shabby.
I wouldn't go above the 10 minute recording mark.
I would never, I would never ask someone to record more than a thousand words.
But that's really pushing the upper limits of what I'm comfortable in asking someone.
Yes, they came to me and they were like,
Strony, give me a re-do.
I'll take whatever you throw at me.
I have a very long, this collab has been a year in the making, if you will.
I got reached out by an old acquaintance in another life.
And we initially had agreed upon this collab and she recognized my voice and she went,
come on then.
And I went right, fuck it, let's do it.
So I've got an old acquaintance collab coming out which I'm very excited about.
No, not a dwarf, not a dwarf, not a dwarf.
Before anyone starts, nope, not a dwarf, not a dwarf.
Just someone that I had associated with in another life and obviously she recognized the voice.
And I recognized her because I knew about her and we messaged, or she messaged me.
She was like, do you remember?
And I'm like, of course I remember, you numpty.
I've still got the script.
I remember like four, yes.
So I think only one of them is going through.
I don't want to reach out to the other people out of respect that were confirmed just because
if they don't interact with me now, I assume it's because of the agency.
Oh my god, the agency full of lude people.
Meanwhile, we're like fucking Min Max and Wines on...
We're Min Max and Wines on Edgeville Bank, like come on, get a grip.
But yeah, I'm very excited.
It's nice to see people that I've not seen in a very long time and in a different form too.
What level are we?
We, my good re-fing, are 98.
We have less than a million X feet to go.
And we have almost just shy of 5,000 Wines.
Soon we'll be entering the 4,000 mark.
Man, you see what my runescape account looks like?
You should sign in.
Come to Edgeville.
I'm on a free world.
We're on 320, believe it.
We're just chilling in Edgeville doing a little skill.
Making wine that's gonna move.
I understand nothing of that phrase.
My brain won't sound strong and I don't worry about it.
How about you, Min Max?
Explain.
How about...
Wait, I'm really bad at insults.
Hold on, let me think of an insult.
How about you accept the fact that you're Diacel's Avon?
Yeah, how about that?
Yeah.
Yeah, you just sit on that one.
You just sit on that one, mate.
Yeah.
That's the best I got.
It's the best I got, you're Diacel's Avon.
They are...
As sin likes to say,
your nan's got nail arms, nail legs, and lips in a pillowcase.
What does it mean?
We don't know.
What?
Yeah, but your mom's a slut.
How dare you?
When we get our MLM VTuber,
most U.K. insults.
Okay, so in the U.K.,
there's this makeup magazine, okay?
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Thank you for becoming a member.
What's that?
How did you activate the sound alert when you did that?
I thought I didn't activate it.
Am I going mental?
Anyway, first off, thank you for coming a member.
I am going to be ordering the girls
next round of emotes
either in two days' time
or today, depending on
what goes on.
Acid in me first.
The twins first, if you will.
My lovely twins.
I do love my twins.
Are you squiddin' me?
Ah, bless the shimmy.
Okay, it does ping.
I thought it didn't make noise.
I think I might...
I just need to know.
No, you cannot help me.
Thank you.
I'm beyond help.
Literally, 5.1K already.
Hydration check.
I was expecting brain.
Oh, like selling newspapers.
So, yeah, sorry.
Back to the Avon.
Avon is a magazine of makeup, okay?
And people come to your door
and are like,
do you want to order off of this magazine?
It's the most bizarre system, okay?
But it's like...
It's like a scam in terms of
you pay astronomical prices
because there's a middleman type thing.
But you prey upon your friends and family
and order through you.
Do you want to order?
You know what?
I've gone so far.
It's so long without saying that.
And you introduced brain rot back to me.
How dare you?
Right, okay, actual hydration time.
Oh, it probably...
Basically, you know,
your friends and family are getting preyed on by then,
but what can I say except you're welcome
for the sun to see the sky?
Hey, it's okay.
Okay, you're welcome.
Hi, mom, how are you, Flynn?
So it's like Tupperware?
No, it's like makeup, like foundation, mascara.
Although they do have a few bits and bulbs.
And it's just...
But basically, it's a bad job
in terms of, you know,
at the end of the day,
there's a markup for something
that someone could go do themselves.
And really, it's old biddies
that can't go to the shops
or can't get out that much
or didn't know how internet shopping works type thing.
But internet shopping kind of killed the job
if you would like to refer to it in that terminology.
Now, don't get me wrong.
I'm not dogging on the job.
I'm dogging on what it is.
You know, I don't care what you do.
I used to clean toilets for a living.
I used to be a dishwasher.
I used to fucking wipe ass for a living.
I couldn't give less of a shit what your job role is.
Sure, I've already been there and done that, okay?
I do not judge the job.
What I judge is what the job actually is
if, you know, the end game is like, you know, bad.
Tupperware, the company,
has the same business model in the US.
Oh!
There's a company called Tupperware.
Okay.
Stroney is a hard worker.
Now, the dishwashing job, honestly...
Honestly, the dishwashing job was good.
Waitress was Polgar's.
Working in the care home was rough.
I used to be an outdoor painter
because I never got qualified for, like, interior.
So I could only do sheds and fences, really.
That was a bit short-lived, though.
I have to admit.
The painting was rough as I did.
It was so sore on your, like, shoulder and all of that.
Should have been easy with ten arms, if only.
If only.
Waitress, Stroney.
Oh, you want to make it artwork of me as a waitress?
Yeah.
You want to see an apron
really accentuate my hips even more
and then when I look away?
When I, like, turn around, it's just my...
Did I tell you I got covered in milk at my job?
Um...
I got milk knocked all over me,
and I had to continue my shift
in soaked milk.
Rather disgusting, in all honesty.
I had gone.
No, it was the...
That was an accident.
Oh, 4,000!
It was just one big, like, accident.
Guy didn't, you know.
He was telling a story,
and he opened his arms wide,
just as I was walking past,
but the fucking wingspan on him
clipped me and I knocked milk all over my shirt.
So...
I had to...
I think I had another, like, four hours of my shift to go,
and I learned the hard way
to bring an extra...
change of clothes...
when I work after that.
It was a white shirt.
No, thankfully.
It was a black shirt.
So it didn't become see-through,
but...
I wear...
flattening bras, I guess,
in terms of, like, I'm really flat.
So it did not...
It's not like anything would have shown anyway.
And all that.
I probably didn't have my piercings either at the time,
so it's not like it would stick out.
Yeah.
A bralette.
Honestly, trainer bra might as well.
I don't know who I'm kidding.
Waitress Johnny as an architect
must have been a minute.
No!
No, I...
I couldn't...
even though, like, I really enjoy the...
the special interest of...
How many of you fuckers have fucking cooking caves,
you little shit?
Are there four of you now?
God damn.
All these are cooking steaks.
Why do you need a bra if nothing...
to hold?
Right.
Well, I tell you an actual factual thing.
So who here has heard
that if a woman does not wear a bra,
that her goobers get bigger in size?
Who has heard this little saying?
I wonder.
I have curiosity if you have heard such a thing before.
We're just to MLG Pro at this game clearly.
Is that a fact?
Nope, you've never heard of it.
Is it real?
Nope, isn't it real?
Oh, you've never heard...
Oh, okay, I guess it must be a woman thing then.
Okay, so there is a saying that
if you do not wear a bra,
that your goobers get bigger, okay?
The reason why your goobers get bigger
is because they start sagging, mother fucker.
See, mine, I have always worn
a very tight fitting bra, okay?
This has resulted in...
and also I don't have any jeans to have milk or somehow,
even though my mom's like a quadruple fucking eff or something.
My mom's got the biggest fucking honkers ever,
and I'm flat-chested.
Where did it all go wrong, Refunds?
Where did it all go wrong?
Yeah, it doesn't work like that.
No, but because I have always been strapped with a bra,
my honkers are like...
you know, they didn't, I think.
Oh, the genetics does play into it.
There is like genetics that play into it as well,
but because I had nothing to begin with,
there's no gravity at all.
You know what I mean?
You just have fake eff cups.
I just went to your butt.
Honestly, true, Andrea.
My butt, my thingy.
I'm wanting to start being a bit more shapely
in terms of like going for walks
or like doing low workouts and stuff,
because I want a fat ass to suffocate you with.
I'm not even kidding, I'm not even...
Small chest is pretty good though.
Unrelated, but did you have a uniform in your waitress job?
No, we just had to put wee pennies on.
It's like the wee thing that goes around your hip
and I actually accidentally stole it once by accident.
I was like, I had to take it from my boss.
I was like, I see, I stole it.
Because a smaller chest means we can be closer to your heart.
Yeah, you can also hear the clacking of my rib cage
because there's nothing else going on there.
I'm really pushing the mood for a nice little sleep scene.
4.8 already, we're getting this again.
Stress-free, strong, also getting fit.
No matter if everything's good, hold the line.
Literally, I'm like, oh my god, I feel better.
I want to start going on my walks again.
I want to start doing my weighted workouts
because I've got weights for my legs.
Well, no, sorry, my apologies.
That's not how it's explained.
Is it done, Bells, that you lift for your arms?
Basically, I do weighted workouts for my legs with those
so I will do lunges with them at either side
so my legs are getting more activated type of thing.
I used to do that.
All this kind of stuff.
Because the stress be going, I'm like, oh my god,
I want to do this, I want to do that.
I want to have this for my refunds.
Don't skip arm day.
I never do my arms.
I always just, I just max on my legs.
I like my legs the most.
Yeah, dumb Bells.
Like these, but one-handed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, explain things to me in emojis.
I'll get it instantly.
Strani, do you think you could crush a watermelon with your thighs?
Should we try?
I think we should.
Do a donut thong stream?
Wait a minute, why do it for a donut thong
if I'm doing a thigh cam stream, like, literally in how many days?
I might go to the shops and get a watermelon.
But what happens if I can't do it?
That's embarrassing.
I've not worked out since debut.
Hmm, that's embarrassing.
I'm a guy, I'm pretty skinny, but all my fat goes to my thighs.
Weight distribution on men and women is different to you.
Guys get a go-out, which is really cute.
I like it.
Whereas women is like, it gets spread around the body
in preparation for pregnancy.
You can try, I've seen clips, but no, it seems very difficult.
Then put a print of a refill on it.
Use a banana instead.
You want me to squeeze a banana with my thighs?
I mean, I'm not going to argue if that's what you want.
Look, you're in control of the content here.
What do you mean you didn't want to pick another forever session of RuneScape?
Shut up and enjoy the gameplay, okay?
Look at the, look at the tick, tick, tick, tick.
Come on.
Squeeze a cherry, that would be quite messy.
Yeah, fat distribution.
Buy two so you can test it.
I don't think you, I'm not entirely sure how to even crush anything between my legs.
I mean, could give it a shot.
Give it a shot, why not?
Because I could definitely like lie on the floor and try,
imagine the grip strength that mummy would have on multiple areas, the gameplay.
It sounds like a little banana cream.
Buying a bunch of fruit to try and see if you can crush them.
Honestly, that would probably be more interesting than just like thigh cupping ASMR stream.
Cause, I don't know, I'm like, I'm not boring in terms of that.
I'm just like, I can't really make it more exciting than, you know, just two hours of my thighs being in the camera.
But I mean, then again, if people like it, who am I to argue?
Gee, I ain't arguing.
But yeah, maybe I should.
I'll buy a bunch of different fruit, fruit crushing ASMR stream.
My tent.
Oh my god, you got a little pet.
Oh my god, look at the pet.
Show me the reflin one.
Is that the reflin one there?
See it?
That's like a little thing.
Rainscape yak session is exactly what I signed up for.
Oh boy, you're in luck.
You're a cute one.
Do you like squeaky toy?
Just plan ahead if you want to crush fruit, I could imagine it gets messy.
Yeah, I was basically just going to put a bunch of towels on the floor.
That's the best I got.
Although I'm in a rental so I need to behave.
Last thing you want is like rotten fruit smell on the carpet.
That's amazing.
But I couldn't get like that plastic stuff because that wouldn't be ASMR.
I'm so glad I found that clip of y'all.
Is that the smoothie that I swear?
So many people found us from smoothie.
A what?
I'm like what?
What?
Is this?
Are you American?
Be honest right now, tiny spiny.
But I will instead be crushing you, crushing a dana mall.
Who's dana mall and why does he have a cup?
What is this?
What is a dana mall?
Is this a reference?
Is it an American reference?
It's basically yogurt and a cup.
The crush, what?
Crush cup advertising.
Who you on about?
Hold on, we're maxing, we're maxing checks.
Oh my god, smooth and crunchy.
Oh my god, I know that meme.
It's the one where it's like smooth and crunchy.
So what does the animals' crunches feel like in your mouth?
Why is this right?
It's a crunchy.
This is the perfect brain roll for me.
It's both smooth and crunchy.
That's not even what I was referencing.
We'll get rekt because I referenced it.
Oh guys, it's both smooth and crunchy.
And then a random monkey comes on the screen.
Why?
Okay, but yeah, basically, right, fuck it.
We're gonna be crushing fruit on that ASMR stream.
Her zoomer brain rolls to advance.
Me, Gibberish, I, Melan, basically.
Reethlings only see mummy after missing her for five minutes.
Is that how you guys cry?
I always thought you cried like, would you clap on camera?
I would have to stand up for it.
The webcam's gonna be facing downwards
because I have to attach it to a mic stand
in order for it not to move.
But I could go off a screen and clap if you want.
We'd cry like, well, that's what I thought.
It was kind of like, you know.
Can we see the shadow of the tree?
I don't know if the light and the source are,
because the light's at the top,
and then I have a ring light on the right side
just so my face is a bit better.
Eliminated, but I'd be true about the tree.
Yeah, I'll see, I'll see, I'll see.
I'm gonna do a full body stream at one point.
Relax! Let me finish the sentence.
Let me finish the sentence
before you start taping fingers off the key!
For one of my Donathon goals,
I want to do a full tactical dress-up.
But the thing with the full tactical dress-up
is you put like the black marker on your eye area
so you can't see anything, okay?
So I'm not ruining the illusion
because you can't see anything on the face.
I also want to do a Rebecca neck down stream,
so I'ma paint myself fucking blue at one point.
So as always, you know, if you're like someone
that doesn't really like that stuff being broken,
then please feel free to check out my gen mates,
because I am blackface.
No, motherfucker.
It's combat tactical shite, you put on your eyes.
She's transforming into Slenderman?
Absolutely not.
Not with his elongated arms.
What do you think?
Mummy as Rebecca would be hot.
I so badly want to cosplay as Rebecca.
But Rebecca is red after being...
You know what?
Will you be blinded?
Oh my god, wait!
I never even thought
would V-Trip Studio be able to...
No, I can see my eyeballs.
I'm sure V-Trip Studio can see my eyeballs.
But I may...
Oh no, I'm worn,
because my entire face is going to be covered
in tactical gear.
Oh, I never thought that far ahead.
Did I now?
Hold on a minute.
Oh no.
Oh no, this can't be.
I never thought that far ahead.
Chaisa.
Good va...
Yeah.
Blah.
Oh, what the fuck was that?
Did I just eat?
No.
What was that?
Did you see the...
What's a booze at that point?
I'm too smart,
even if you simply misrhythmize it.
PNJTuber.
Stronifying new possibilities.
Try it all stream.
I didn't know you liked military gear.
I like the...
What have I done?
Okay.
Oh my god, I've done sautin'.
I've done...
I've...
Yep.
Hold on.
No, don't log out.
Shit.
Okay.
Law...
Hold on.
What have I done?
Okay.
Can I go to the bank, boo?
Have I fixed it?
Press alt.
Okay.
Okay, thank you.
Holy shit.
That...
Look, I'm not gonna lie.
We got stun locked.
We literally got soft locked in the game there.
Because of my stupidity.
Please understand, small brain.
Strongly, that stream Bravo 6 is going dark.
Fatass and no boo boo,
Rebecca Cosplay for sure.
Real and true.
Why do you say Shaisa all the time?
I just like swearing in different languages.
I said what I said, okay?
I said what I said.
A little cheeky sucabliette here.
A little bordello here.
What else?
A little cazzo.
Cazzo merda.
Puta madre.
What else do I know?
Bef.
What's French?
Merd.
Do I know swearing in any other languages?
I don't think so.
I think that's pretty much it.
Cazzo merda.
Puta.
Oh, puta.
Okay, how could I forget?
How could I forget the Viva la France?
Can you call us horrible things, please?
In English?
Are you secretly one of those tactical Cosplay girls
that I keep seeing on my Twitter homepage?
I actually caught in 40.
Everyone thinks that I'm busy
with all those behind-the-scenes work.
I'm thoughtin' about in them tactical,
red ears.
Puta.
Not putin'.
Cazzo.
If you want to know what Son of a...
is in her...
for guys...
Her...
Oh, Hurrenzon.
I've been told Hurrenzon, you know.
Yeah.
Beep.
Ha ha.
Ik ben slim.
I don't know how to say I know.
Ik ken dat?
I know that.
I think it's Dutch.
Just say I know that in Dutch.
Ik ken dat?
No, did I just make that up?
I mean, I just made that up.
Sorry, Xie.
Isn't it puta?
I just love to...
I just love to fuck while wearing a ghillie, honestly.
Do you remember that fucking...
Was it Modern Warfare 2 map where people...
No, it was called 4.
Oh my god, I was literally a baby on that game,
and I remember someone was shootin' at me
from under the map, and I think it's so annoying.
Ik ken dat?
I know that.
With your accent, you could go through as a German.
Hallo, Leiter.
Wait, what's the Scottish accent on German?
Wie geht's gut und dir?
Dainenmutter is in Schweinhand.
Das is gut, ja.
Is das Gras road?
Nein, das Gras is groin.
Ja, ja, that's...
German.
Scots is not happening anytime soon.
I am not poppin' up on Duolingo.
Okay, this feels so...
That was fowl.
Ja, nein.
Das was...
Ja, da.
East Liebes fans.
Ja, ja.
Yes, I guess, I guess.
That's a Dutch fireman on the floor.
I don't know what Scottish Dutch would sound like.
Hallo, ich ben Sturoni-Cuttles.
Ich wohne in Schotland.
Ich bin...
Ich heb...
Oh my god, Jüngen becomes Jüngen in Scottish Dutch.
What about French?
Bonjour, c'est la vie.
Je m'appelle Sturoni-Cuttles.
J'ai a beat, oh, et cos.
J'ai...
J'ai joué...
Runescape.
Yeah, that's just...
That's absolutely awful.
Let's not do that.
Please, someone cut that's awful.
If you want to know the German equivalent of Slag is...
Schlum.
Dain and Mutter is in Schlump.
Pee.
Schlump.
She's so good.
German is a bit similar to Swedish.
You just have to sound German and talk aggressively.
Hallo, leurophasket.
Du bist kutscha.
I don't know.
Volkswagen.
The Krankenmobil.
It's the...
That's because I've tried desperately to scramble for one more thing.
What is Dain and Mutter?
It's your mum.
Dain and Mutter in German, your mum.
So, to say your mum is a pig in German,
we say Dain and Mutter, your mum,
is a Schweinhound, is a pig.
This is a Flamenwaffe.
Hans gets the Flamenwaffe.
Isn't Dain and Mutter that game with the pink board?
What?
This is a video game reference.
I don't know.
Tristan Schreiner.
World Domination Gumpalger's Champuses.
I've planned out my next hypno stream.
So, I'm going to do a hypno stream live
where I get you to forget your name
and you become a reflin.
However, I'm also going to make it a separate video.
I will change it up a bit,
but my next hypno stream is going to be Forget Your Name.
And I may or may not want you to drill a little bit on yourself,
but that's just for me and my side.
Because I think it'll be really cute if you drill on yourself.
But that's just me.
And it makes me...
Yeah, that's a lot, so...
Look, I snotty.
I'm bad for it.
But I'm a reflin already.
No, you have to forget your name.
I'm going to train you to not respond to your actual name.
And you become a reflin.
Making you drill when mommy angst.
Bummy angst when you drill.
I just think it's really hot.
I said it.
It's like sizzling like a sirloin steak in a skillet hole.
The game with pink blood is Danganronpa.
I keep hearing about that game.
I'm going to start playing it in a minute.
I'll hear about it all the time.
That's like the third time in a week that it's been brought up.
Is that a massive series?
I think you guys said it was a VN though.
Me, Send and Mercy, play it first.
See if she likes it or not, and then I'll play it.
It's a mystery series game.
Don't? Oh, someone just strapped it and said don't.
I just like the idea that you're so in a spell that you're legit drilling
and you don't know until you're on the other end.
I can do it with an Asian accent.
I'm part Asian.
I ain't saying that out loud.
Yeah, VN is a pretty popular one.
Danganronpa is a crime visual novel.
I can make myself drill by napping in the day while listening to ASMR.
I wish it could be fulfilled.
We're already hypnotized by your charm.
You want complete control of us.
Is that so much to ask for?
Maybe I don't want to destroy all of humanity.
Maybe I just want my wiflings and I to have a very good thing.
Some Swedish lore.
Just want to enslave it.
Saliva is the top five.
Why are you drinking emote to that?
Actually, I don't need to hydrate though.
Oh my God, we're at 4.1.
Hydration check.
Hypnotize me, mommy.
Soon.
Make it top two.
Okay.
Right.
Make it top two.
Wait, what's number one?
My anchor, yours.
Mommy, cute mommy.
Why are you crying over mommy?
Take control of me, mommy.
Don't forget to click her for mommy training.
Bear.
I'm waiting on my freaking collar to come.
So I can put it on and take cute pictures.
Don't need to destroy humanity when you can just destroy our mains.
Real and true, okay?
Real and true.
Hold on, let me open up marshmallows.
Yeah, it's little pen.
Little penny for bone prostate health.
See that? Look, first thing open up
and we're all looking after each other's paw.
Can I put my mom on?
Finished watching the void.
My favorite parts were wreathlings, you can burp.
Darling, ten out of ten.
Ten out of ten, my wreathlings can burp.
Sleepy wreathlings, collabs feel more comfortable for you now.
What are you analizing? You've just thrown me into this.
I'm glad I say stream workers going well now that you're motivated.
Also, no, I hate the vocal fry.
What are you talking about?
What? You don't like my vocal fry?
What's wrong?
You don't want to listen to a beach uber with a vocal fry.
What's wrong? You don't like this?
It sounds like I have those devices.
You don't like that?
Could you imagine?
Cute wreathling with crown being your kingling.
All the meme references in the game, the dirty boy voice acting part.
The brat from misunderstand and the destruction.
By the way, Strony, you never mentioned what happened to your work after stream.
Look, all I'm going to see.
My ability to polish the pair of lessons has returned, okay?
And I'm going to take it out on all of you.
Do you understand?
Mark my words. I am taking it out on all of you.
I think I've got maybe two more days of work.
If I manage to pull it out in years.
Hold the line. Don't threaten me with a good time.
I understand. We may have volunteered.
We're so back. Looking forward to it.
We're finished.
Don't look at old words for chocolate.
Olivia, something racist.
Oh no, don't do that. Please don't stop.
To Valhalla, honestly.
It's cute that in your new life you can unleash your inner true zimmer.
Isn't it really bad this time around?
I definitely held myself back in another life.
I was like...
But now I'm just like, yep, this is me.
And you have to tolerance that.
Another thing, the art you posted recently.
My ink sac hurt again.
Holding back is hard.
Are you waiting?
Are you waiting for the picture?
Can you imagine it now?
What kind of poses I'm going to be in?
My tripod is quivering with anticipation.
The coconut oil bottle is quivering with anticipation.
I'm watching the anagings I'm going to be getting up to.
It's the moment we've all been waiting on to be two months.
That's how long it took me.
I expect to be completely destroyed.
If you say it like that, we'll be...
So say stuff like that, what do you mean?
It's not a threat, it's a promise.
Wait, no, other way around.
It's not a promise, wait.
You know what I'm saying, I'm trying to say.
Not just the tripod and the oil.
I'm going to try body writing.
I have markers and I'm going to try and write stuff on it.
And be like, I'm going to try and do different things.
So it's like, one's like I'm Riefling's property.
Like only for Riefling type thing.
Like Riefling's tongue here.
And like derogatory and that kind of stuff.
I'm going to see what happens.
It's not very easy to write on myself.
I'm literally going to have to be like lifting my leg behind my head
in order to write on myself.
So I'll be very curious to see how it comes out.
The thigh cam, stream sense.
She's marking us, oh dear.
Right too small.
Well, I can wipe off.
It's not like...
I can wipe off.
It's just really difficult.
So if my like pale pasty skin doesn't look pasty and pale
it's because I've messed up so many times trying to take it off
and put it back on again.
Because I was going to do loads of different variations of it.
You're certainly something.
I hope you know that.
Thanks is the autism.
It's the...
I don't even know.
I mean it's just the wombo combo of them both.
But yeah.
I'm going to see if I can do a little turkey gift as well.
I think that would be cute.
And I'm going to put a big two on one cheek
and then a big zero on the other.
And then see if I can get a little torque gift for that.
I thought that would be cute.
Just don't wipe off your hard work when adding the oil.
Well, that's the thing.
I would have to do the oil last.
So basically is do the stuff without anything on me.
Then do the right end.
And then once I'm satisfied, completely take off all the right end.
But obviously my skin is going to be stained black at that point.
And then do the oil stuff that I want to do.
And then I think that'll be it.
I'll kind of have to look over.
You're wonderful just the way you are.
Thanks.
I came out like this.
Never change.
And so you didn't jump around a pole and sing mid-summer.
You're untrue.
This is too much excitement.
I like doing stuff that you guys actually want.
Because it's like, well, you want it.
I'm not just like taking a stab in the dark.
I was like, no, you guys, if you want it, you get in it.
Sorry, I keep this.
I don't know if you can see it down here.
This space is getting bigger and bigger next to skullfish.
It's just getting bigger and bigger and bigger.
Because I keep trying to think of the anticipation of crazy.
Your latest NSF tweet with the art attached to skullfish.
Oh, you liked it.
I'm glad.
Okay, well, Stony, I want you to sit on my face.
The only time I can do that is the convention.
I can't wait to be kicked out.
Oh, I can't wait to be kicked out.
What are you doing?
Are we doing it?
If we did not hear some other raga in it...
I opened up Twitter and got jumpsfared.
By what?
What shenanigans are the girls up to know?
My face is red, Ace Marble.
Bonjour!
Salut!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I am sorry I left two French words.
Sorry, I can't speak French
I'm in total clear
You can get nothing else from me. Oh no
Tonight in Melbourne news down under locos wait tonight in the Melbourne news down under local
Scottish woman is kicked out of a country for breaking
20,000 necks by sitting on the faces of their
Now it is true that she was trying to become a citizen, but they want to accept her so she's getting kicked out back to Scotland
So adorable
No, I just know how I'm gonna I unironically think I'm getting denied the right to the country and I think I'm gonna have to
Stream from a hotel room whilst I make my pitfall way back to Scotland do I see
I'm just not good at getting hit
I
Don't know what's happening with that, but that is life. It is a funny story good come back to Scotland is better here
Anyway, it's fucking miserable. My family's like oh, it's boiling hot one thing then it's frozen the next and I'm like
I
Say that as if
The houses are just out of shape
So did you know that double glazing isn't a thing in Australia?
If you didn't know double glazing keeps the heat out and keeps the warm in and maintains the temperature of the inside of the building
Okay, and it's not common here only single pain is for some reason and
Because it's not common. It's astronomical
Scotland is just rain wait only single pain when literally
It
Literally in the country where it gets a bail in hot like it literally gets like bailing hot to like 45 degrees in the summer
Or whatever and they went single pain windows so all the heat can leak in please. I'm like
Whose logic is this because it's no mine
It's no my logic so is Bush. I'm just I'm having it
No my logic
Oh, so you're talking about doughnuts. I mean if you want me to stack them on it like get it up. It's up to you
Double glazing strong. Oh
I get it now
I understand the random doughnut comment because I was like what you on about right I get it now I get it now
My apologies. I'm a bit slow. I'm a bit slow. We've got there in the end
I
Think you've got double glazing for me. Are you more of a single glaze kind of we flim, huh?
wait, what and
Glazing is a terminology for doughnuts and you put like a sugary glaze on top of it
But because the sugary glaze looks a little bit transparent sometimes suspicious
The glaze can also be referred to as in a different act that occurs between a
Strony and a refling
You can have double glazed windows absolutely and
You mean like
That you put in the walls
Maybe I don't know
Do you have mercy do not have mercy on us?
You can double glaze the strongy if I save up at all currently 26 in my room at 9 p.m. Yeah
Yeah
So what the doughnuts refer to we need examples it
Well mad doughnut is slang terminology for the old starfish
Why why is it every time I see someone streaming this game? I see the building at this
exact spot our old buildings the same and
So we're in a place called edgeville
But the bank is here and
But people can do it at the Grand Exchange, but there's a lot of spammers and bots as for other banks
I mean you could technically be at the top of Lumbridge, but edgeville is a good location, especially for free players
We are not doing membership stuff
That mood
Hurry
It's just a really convenient spot
Have you ever used a scottish bagpipe? No, they're very expensive and inaccessible to most people
And I've seen people use them, but I've never touched one
There was a kid in my school that was getting like lessons in it and
Yeah, do those things
expensive
Just asking Johnny how I can start with RuneScoop. It is a journey you take on your own
Um
Like I played it as a child. I had no idea what I was doing the numbers went off. I kept going and
Yeah, time for a bagpipe. I am not playing them. I do not like bagpipes the drone of it is so annoying
I
Risk of getting insta-ban. I'll say I wouldn't mind double glazing. We're not we're not that bad around here
I like to think that my my mods might my my moderators. Thank you to the hidden heroes of the stream. Um,
They were all on the same page
You know a little cheeky strong a bagpipe fund. Absolutely not
absolutely not
No chance
Fake scott hates bagpipes. It's like mongolian throat singing. It's that drone like that
And then bagpipes are also a freaking thing, okay
Um
We will make you love mongolian throat singing how dare you
Yeah
It's not happening
We're at three thousand six hundred
Or we're getting so tiny
We're getting so tiny sorry
Okay, let me let me check marshmallow. I'm an oldie
Uh, I'm sorry mommy. I really wish I could send an audio or video for you
But because of my living situation I can oh don't worry about you don't have to do that
At least I can offer up a scenario for you to think about dare we read it. Is this going to be too saucy?
Well, let me man, Mac
So I wish I could be your living maid wearing nothing but an apron or whatever you want and I take care of things around the house
Well, you're working hard on top of that. I am free use. Okay, I do
I
Okay, that's a cute scenario. I like it free use rethink
Hey mommy, I'd like to recommend a game sheepy a short adventure is free cute and short
Hmm. Is that because we played the
um
It's that because we played the
The turnip boy robs a nope that comes next week. Oh my god. I'm leaking my my content next week. I'm leaking all over the chair
I'm trying to draw circles why they even know if I'm drawing how close the straw need a leveling up. Um, we
are the halfway mark
We've got the 3000 more to go so that'll take us to just over an hour
Maybe just shy of two hours
I'm not sure you guys will be able to guess to make better than me
I'm a fake rinscape player. I just do this for male attention
Okay, right, right, right. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. This stream was pre-recorded. No, it wasn't
Stop it's not pre-recorded. That's not even today's date
Today's date is 5 41 a.m
on
The ninth of the eighth month
Stop they're gonna believe it
You're winding me up your success, but it was recorded a week before it. No, it wasn't. I was literally live at this time a week ago
Live on stream. I stream every day
They're winding me up
They're winning
Pre-recorded stream. Mommy hates no
Pre-recorded for male attention real and true
Guys, there's a meal doing her gameplay far out. Stop every player winding me up
I'm sure there was a
Like that or they're pretending to play
Hey, we'll make it back from a week-long cruise in Alaska
Alaska hardly even know her
Okay
And took a lot of pics. Do you want to see them? Why not? Oh my god
Did you see any animals?
Or every time I hear Alaska, I think of two things snow and wild animals. That's it
The chapters are a figment of my imagination. Take my mates. I'm never taking my mates again ever
She says that she's currently on beta blokers for her heart
Get off the stage pre-recorded and letting someone
Other do it just so she has to she can reply to the app. How can she pre-recorded? She hates us
You're giving the refling brainwarp stop it
bunk
Yeah, maybe with all the excitement I'd only need one thrust
But as you've learned some of us can more go more than one round
So either way you're leaving satisfied
You'll be learning to what you'll be leaving with a funny walk after I do your back door
Oh
A refling. Oh, it's all grapes
I'll be all grape in you in a minute. Whoa, you can't say that
Take your meds the reflins can't be your coping mechanism
The end the incident wasn't your fault that accident wasn't me
There's no way it's her playing at this extremely high skill level someone else's on the keyboard
Honestly, the clicking is just too much for the the wham and brain to comprehend. Look at that
See how see how before I was crossing off the tab and then mixing them and then confirming
Look at all that wasted time. No, I'm just
The current date is the 1st of august. Ah, that's it bend over
There's only one way to deal with misbehaving reflins
There's only one game first rinse game stream. I'm glad to be here to see the money shot literally like what one
Everway, maybe
No mummy madona. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, you're talking about glazing madona bend over
No more
You're not getting me
And put that oh my god the skills the skills
Hi strawny. Hi reflin. I want to drink your saliva every day until just the thought your saliva makes me thirsty
Are you squidding me right now?
My little reflin
Come on stream chat and strawny already flirting
Come on, I lean
If you can't come
enter
Mezzo come on her now playing come on. I lean
Thank you. Sorry. Yeah. I bw for the
So true this stinger is coming out we've seen reflin
I was laughing when I used my loading screen on the ac collab
and
Because she was like we're obviously we're just trying to wait before the stream and she was like, uh, do you want to use it or
No, and I'm and I was like, oh, I don't normally she was like, yeah, no, that's why I'm asking
I'm like, oh, okay. I'll use I'll use it. So we agreed to come up at the same time
But I probably gave some of yous a heart attack scene the loading screen
But it's because I need to be professional
How many hours of sleep did you get refling and I swear if one of you goes like two hours because I wake up in the middle
Of my sleep just to watch you naughty spanking
You use what impossible stretch. Oh, you want me straight right now?
Half an hour. No, we're only deranged because of moment and because of the hypnosis
Well, we're at 3.4
I'm gonna be in the twos
I saw it eight hours five hours eight ten eight four
I haven't slept just three a.m. For you
You're in the same country as me
Hold on a minute. Let me do some math. You're in the same land mass as me. But where I'm currently triangulating your position right now
Oh my god, you're in Paris. What the fuck open your mouth
Please forgive me. I can't believe this is really oh
Great leg muscles are leading cause of back pain stretching is good
You know, there's other kinds of stretch and that really helped the body
Paris bro still losing a shit about me. Well, that's a lovely straw. Yeah, yeah, thanks for that
It's 3 a.m
Not 3 a.m. 5 a.m. Yeah 5 a.m
You're super cool and in the coolest time zone if it's 5 a.m. Right now
You're in the coolest ever time zone
What happens if we like kissed in the same time zone?
You miss them
Perth bros, why is your response? Yeah, you play all through runescape. Yeah, I'm getting my first skill cape today. Look look look looky
We're almost there. We have
3000 more wines to go
And then we've got my first ever skill cape
You should play subnautica go back to the sea they're cuttlefish and reef
backs and reef laying
Um, yeah, I've been asked to play a few times. Look at that
I'm in the opposite time zone of woman. It's almost nine a night. Yeah getting
Brian strony the type of gal to be a bratty dork until you sit the bratty cuttlefish on your lap and then folds like origami
strontagami
I do like him
I'm not no
No, wrong. Sorry. Yeah
Wrong
Very
No, that's completely false
And you can't prove either that I get intimidated. Okay
You can't prove that I get intimidated
I'm gonna shine
I just get shy, okay
Can we make thunder and lightning together?
Oh, that's actually really good. ASMR stream. I make thunder and lightning
That note doesn't sound really confident
Can you name your gamer sub soodle noodle? Oh my god, by the way, I looked at the gamer sub statistics
Thank you to like anyone and everyone who I run. Oh speaking of gamer subs for anyone who
Unironically dead use code strony at checkout. Uh, thank you
Uh, I appreciate it. It helps it a lot if you didn't know mercy received her pr package
I also have the pr package. Um
Type thing from them. I mean we could go through it together. I'm a bit boring though
I'm not sure if I could make it fun unless it was just like a regular hand cam
Stream, I'm not sure. Hmm. Let them know use code strony for 10% off gamer subs, literally
Um, but yeah, thank you to everyone who has
um
gone for it
a
Yeah, I checked out my statistics. I was surprised. Yeah, you can fold her full nelson style
She said so herself that she can put her ankles behind her ears
I said that in confidence reflin
You can't just say it's so present
I said that in confidence
Uh
Thank you, sorry and where's the tip?
Motherfucker
There's fan art of that
Oh, can't we towards the very weak
Should call one of your gamer subs flavors clam chowder on i'm not
So i'm gonna try and be a bit devious once there's a few more sales. I'm gonna see if they're willing to um
They they did say we can publicly release what the numbers are in terms of what would
Get us a cup
Um
But if it goes well, um, then
We'll ask for a cup. Um, and then if it continues to go well
Then we could be cheeky shites and ask for a flavor, but I think it would be a group flavor. It wouldn't be like a
It wouldn't be a thing out of all the energy drinks. I'm trying to coffee. So is the best
Yeah, I'm not I'm not expecting you to
Oh, did certain flavors get held or cut open at checkout because of rules. I know vv had some stuff checked out
Uh, I didn't open the box inspect element on it. Um
Maybe I should
Have so much space look look how far these spaces go in. It's just chaos in this little bar
You think we wouldn't watch gamer soaps after watching tens of thousands of wines. We're all in baby
I may I don't know. Maybe at the
Maybe just make it a minute, but then I could make it an education and be like this is what a pr package looks like
Mercy's done one recently. I'll wait to see if anyone else wants to do one and if not then I
I'm gonna message gamer sips and be like, hey
I'm allowed to talk about this process and maybe make it more an educational stream about what the process was like because
And acapella media were super nice
Like I literally yapped and like leaked all the secrets about what I'm buying the scenes and they were like, this is amazing
We're gonna make a youtube video and I'm like, what the fuck?
Um, but yeah, I'll ask them and I'll see and then maybe turn into an educational stream with a pr package or so
and
Should call it cuttlefish ink
Shut up and take my bottle cap. I love that currency. I think it's such a good currency
Fallout were they they cooked with that. Oh, yeah, someone cooked with that one
We watch everything mummy does on spiny
Sups flavor siren slurp juice
scrawny substance
What would everyone's flavors be called
Did you hear my stomach there
Hello rumble
Do you are you watching any anime we're watching?
Sugar sweet life shit, I don't know what it's called. We're watching it very shortly
We're watching is my happy sugar life or something like that. I'm so sorry
The happy sugar life. Okay. I got it. I got it baby. I got it
Um, we're watching an anime next week together
Because I'm gonna start a series called turn me into a weep and if it goes well then
Every month. I think we'll watch one anime together
and if it doesn't really work out how I plan then
you know, I'll just
do gaming as I always do because
Definitely a gamer over a weave, but if you prefer more weave orientated VTubers, definitely check out Zura. Um
She she knows everything
And I'm like, hmm. Yes. I've never heard of this before
Apparently something happened in my hero academia nuts. Okay
I don't know what happened in my hero
But apparently it was terrible and everyone has left with a a bad taste in their mouth
It just ended or officially ended
I mean, are we allowed to talk about it?
And you guys just give me the rundown because I watched for froppy and then I gave up in season two because the fillers were starting to kill me a bit
Hmm
L ending L Deku lamest shonen character. Oh, right
Uh, banha the ending
Like every shonen ending is kind of not written
cute
Mummy cute mummy wife. Mummy look like the love of my life. Oh, that's so cute. What the fuck?
That's a cute little model
Um, it was rushed and anti-climactic at the end. I just watched the first season. Yeah, it was awful
Deku's mom said chubby so it's a win-win. Lamal, that's the note bars. Trauny flavor brainy starfish
Speaking of my starfish, I'm away for a fart
That was the quietest fart. I didn't even have to mute for that. I'm gonna be honest
Froppy that would be good ASMR. They turned Deku emo
Is is that why emi's in shambles right now?
She she needed a week off
I'm teasing by the way. She got banned by estaban a fucking rat
But it's okay
Are you baking bread?
Um, no
I had anxiety this morning
And my anxiety makes me shit myself
So I woke up and I had a really sore tummy and I went to the toilet. So I have no bread
Like you gotta take the pros with the cons when it comes to abomb. Okay. I'm taking the pros
Um
Bye. I took my my little heart medication my auntie adrenaline. Whatever you want to call it. It's two in one
um
And hopefully I'll be I'll feel better soon. But um
I'm really sure what to what the solution is. There is no present solution at the moment
To my situation
Um
Oh icicle snow berries. Oh my god. I'm so sorry you're watching the most boring gameplay
Versus honey cam studios
Honey cam studios versus click simulator on runescape. I'm gonna be honest honey cam studios definitely is a lot better than
This but thank you for the redirect icicle
Uh, sorry snow berries
Completely do not feel bad for clicking off honey cam studios as a hoot in a holler versus uh runescape
Um
But just to caught up to speed I have three thousand more wines
We're about to hit the two thousands actually and then I have my first ever skill cape on runescape
Which I'm very excited about I'm gonna have to buy a bond because
Apparently in order to claim a runes
Uh a skill cape
You need a bond for it. So you can't even claim it for free
They they really uh shafted three players out of that one. I thought that was a bit egregious
But yes, thank you icicle. Please rest well after you stream
Hey, hi, john. Have you some hi snow berries? Oh, did you enjoy uh honey cam?
We we played at one point did did she outdo my trophy? Did she get a bronze trophy?
Or are a gold or silver a diamond?
Honey cam was great, but that wasn't even anything close to the most unhinged part of that stream
Well, you better clip it so I can turn it into shorts for
I hope you haven't get the yeah anything. She didn't get a trophy. Oh, no
Oh, my wee ac
Um, it was a fever dream of a stream. Is it allowed to stay up?
snowberries
Is the stream allowed to remain?
Was she censoring her words?
Did she say banal?
instead of
There's a going to be so many clips from the stream. Okay. Okay. I'm complaining like the the shorts
The short editors are on standby. So I'm not complaining
If you guys want to load her up
Maybe it might have to be taken down
It is but she was super
After the stream time to check up the stream before it gets new to literally
Oh
But yes, thank you again icicle for the redirect
But yes, snowberries keep you up to date and please don't feel forced to watch the gameplay
I I I know if you're not into runescape. It's not your thing. Don't feel forced. Um, we are cooking wines in edgeville
We are about to get the 99 skillcape today. Um
in
Approximately, we're thieving sitting in there. Um, we are approximately t-minus like two hours away from it
Um, I've just been yapping my head off. Um, we were debating whether it will survive very long
We think we broke her a little but we're so happy. She feels better post stream now
What did you do to my feral polar bear did you break that message her or is she like engaged if you know what i'm saying
uh-huh
Is she busy is she doing is she doing post stream work right now?
What did you do to my polar bear?
They say mind did your mind break my polar bear
Snowberries
Naughty
Naughty boy
I like how it's just followed by silence like no
No, okay, let me check marshmallow
Um
Can you have small things on the side can't like put something three inches between your thighs and my hand just to show off the comparison
Of course
Me acting shocked at such a request. Yeah, sure. No, that's no problem. I'll get a ruler out
I'll go find my ruler. Oh, no. She broke us
Is she didn't that brat deserved it the snowberries have mind breaking abilities too
It was all normal until the voice changer and the dmca free distract wraps began and then everything just wait what what?
What was going on in that stream? She didn't distracts
She's fine. Don't worry. She ended the stream saying she felt much better than when she started
She wrote very specific. That's all the specific
The numbers on stream is different than my chat, but 13.9 million smacker runes
I see this and all of G sun set
Set to the not like a what?
You got this right. I don't how would I distract a refland? Oh, yeah
You're vomiting everywhere call my puke cling
Oh, yeah, you're looking so adorable and defenseless call my
Oh, yeah, sometimes you may be called brish call my tealings
I don't know how I would distract you guys like. Oh, yeah
Like it's it's not happening. Oh, yeah, the one pump jump. I mean thank goodness. I'm a faster
Bomber on his sweater already I'm spaghetti
Something like that
The one punch on hi strani, please read this to yourself
Would you ever consider plugging for a stream?
What gives you the impression I haven't been
Do you imagine
Like unplugging your router, right sure if you want to call it a router
She plugs all the time give her subs 10% off strani could strani look oh
You can't see that I mean if you want me to
I don't mean a little special occasion
It has to it has to be a special occasion though
But what would the special occasion be?
Oh, it's that kind of endurance being
Shit bag if you didn't I've taught you too much. I've taught you too much. It's either double dog
Do not dare you or shite bag if you didn't
Turn it max now and use it for 12 or no that ain't happening
In the way, bro. In the way
Got any toothpicks. No, I don't like it anymore. I don't like to ball it
Hi strani. I'm late. What color are you wearing today?
purple
I have purple today
Start wearing purple for me now
All my sanity and wits they will all vanish. I promise
I pour mummy cute mummy wave mummy can diss me anytime. Oh, no
Unless you like it it's different if you like it
Pre-recorded stream. No, you better. No, it's not pre-recorded
We take you at 30k you want 30k sure. Why not? I don't see why not
Literally, I'm too blind. Why don't I don't see why not?
Hey
You listen to gargle bordello. Oh, you guys knew that
Huh never trust a gamer girl that grew up on xbox. They got that gamer grip in more ways than one
Especially the scott ones. They're like velcro. I swear. Thank you. Sorry. Yeah
um
Actually, I was going to show a picture of my controller
Now you may be saying to yourself strani why what's so important about showing off a controller
I
When I play the binding of Isaac, I played so intensely that I claw my controller
And you can see the indents of how hard
Um, I've clawed my
I was gonna show that I can't believe mummy would pre-record no
But yeah, I was gonna I was gonna do a picture and be like call yourself a gamer
You're not a real gamer until you have to literally replace your
Um
What are they called joy con no joy cons nintendo like do we analog sticks?
Until you have to replace your analog sticks because you can't stop clawing the fucking thing while gaming like a feral beast honestly
Good lord those grippers grip. Jesus. My back is gonna be scarred up literally
When do we analog
Single ball brain
But yeah, I'm purple
Reeflings have a defenseless
A defenseless starfish just like rin po saka from fate
That one to look up this character or is the first thing I'm gonna see is like
They're bare cheeks out
So this is peach my face now deal
I'm needing to get more comfortable. It's an old meme of my apologies
My apologies. Oh my god. We're 2.7. We're doing it 2.7
2.7 god look at the drip from all these reeflings. What the heck you guys are old school runescape
players
Me when you guys play games that I also play I'm just like mind blown
Because like other reeflings had fortnite skins as well and I'm like
You play this game too
Short nail club you can google it should be most blue
It's a cringy line for an arrow gate
Just puts
Put save search on at one point in the visual novel her starfish is described as defenseless
You know what?
Fuck it. Let's look it up
Rinn
And what's the catchphrase defenseless mean?
I want to put
Right the first thing that comes up is I want to put the bone of my sword inside
Starfish and give her a strong heavens feel. I don't think that was the mean
and then the next one
Is
Her her ludeness is
Oh
Oh, I think I found the I found the meme
Oh, yep. That's that's the meme all right. Yep. That's just straight up. Yep. I found the mean
She bones on my sword till I heavens feel
After a lot of vn it's coming up
Yeah
As I pray unlimited cake work
I am the bone of my sword. Oh wait, did I read it wrong? I probably did
Damn a man of fortune and jay must seek my fortune
Henry ivories
Uh, the author was told to put in those scenes so it would sell but he's really bad at writing them. Oh
I mean it does sum up the refunds pretty well though
Like you're a good little stress release one as I said, I get my I get my de-stress and on swing
Um, I don't know if sheepsters is up now. I might be mistaken but
She be maybe
Oh, she's up in two hours, okay, let's get these wines done and we can perfectly redirect into
Whoa, whoa min max min max. Let's go. Oh, she didn't stream today. Oh, man. Oh, she doesn't
Okay
Oh, she changed her profile picture it looks like her now
I'm glad I'm glad it actually looks like her now
My little rabbit
Apparently there's a store in the Netherlands called the refund store. Good
By the power of this command seal, I order you shit. You're what?
If you had a chance to change your fate, would you
sometimes
She might do a gorilla, but only she feels well enough. She was looking after fia. She was sending me repictures
and
I've also been so social with me
Um
She was sending me pictures of fia and I was absolutely adoring it and she looks so precious
She's like such a pretty cat as well. Like I've only ever had Tabby's my whole life
Wait, what bots can talk?
Am I going mental should I be muting someone should I be muting someone?
In the chat monk eyes, sorry, I don't know if there's bot spam going on and I'm ignoring it because I'm yapping away at myself
ellipses
Any survival tips for a gymnasium?
No
We flings come when they aren't
pictures of a we's gone
Yeah, and she was sending me pictures of fia and I was like, oh, she actually has a we's gone
She was so precious and like she had a like a bib on and everything it was so cute
Yeah, so do that bots are ever in the game can't get rid of them for real now just old school runescape crafting bots are these ones
That's a
So these ones the the level three
I remember there's like a big old debate they were like, oh
If you go a bit to the box or the economy
Because everything become expensive or whatever
I'm very curious
Check the fit on this one. Yeah, damn
Oh, we got Gardner
I mean the fit matches is a pretty good fit
That's why a lot of mid game money makers are good again
I personally wouldn't use this particular name anywhere
I'm a swamp witch not Gardner, but your your thing has garden
I mean you do look like a witch because of the hat and that but I would say you're like a nice Gardner that comes from the garden
You're like you're like seedos from beaver pinata because you live in a swamp
I can't I can't choose between the seeds. They're all my favorite
Did she reach big number yet? I'm about to literally I am so close
Wait, I don't have to go like through 99 right like it's done after this one
Right, I don't like have to level up through 99
And like I'm about to get jump-scared and runescape you have to level up through 99 as well. Yeah, it's done at 99
Okay at 99. Thank god
It's a cabbage cape not a skill cape. It's a fake. Sorry. You found out this way. It's not real
It's not real him. Is it hair blower or something?
It should be okay. It would turn into a h word stream. No, it turned into an r word stream real quick
I thought imagine not getting 200 million at no chance
You have to go 120 imagine playing runescape 3 you're like half an hour away
Really?
Am I actually?
I don't am I
I'm 30 minutes away from my first runescape
So I feel like I'm going to be like run into the grand exchange
She'll like get um crafting stuff because apparently you do crafting in like four hours
You maxed out on runescape 3
how
Old-school runescape on mobile. It's on like anything. It's everywhere
I'm staying around then a little dancy dancy
My god, x fees a lot faster in runescape 3. Didn't they not make it equal because if it's 120 levels
You have to gain in runescape 3 wouldn't then just be the same
The fastest max in this game is like 17 days or something
Wait fully maxed out a count
Nah, they were running dragon bones to the altar because there's no way
Yeah, there were two youtubers that raced a honey watch that series
Are you planning on doing anything else once you've got 99 in the cape?
I was gonna do
Um questing together because I'm not very familiar with the quest, but I really enjoyed walking around together
Um, but the only problem with questing is you need membership for it. Basically
And I don't like the idea of stream sniping games that cost money
Like it kind of sucks. She says that she's picked vermin tide 2 this week. I know I know have a critical. Um
But it'll be worth trust trust, okay?
Um, I'm actually needing to play vermin tide to get familiar with the game again because it's been many a while
um
but yeah
They also both just did iron man max speedruns just
Get 99 agility
He
Imagine playing an iron man, couldn't be me
You mean the symbol right here? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Dark tide win. What's dark tide? Is that not vermin tide?
Hypno critical
Quest help her plug in. Yeah, and you guys can help me too because you know what to do and I don't
vermin tide but with guns
I think vermin tide was gifted by steam to all users like a year ago. Wait, really?
That's kind of me. Why would they do something so why would they do something so nice? What the heck?
Oh
It's free for a bit when dark tide, you know, oh to boost like it's thingy
That was like what and that game series we were here did
I think they came out with like the third or fourth installment. So they made the first one free
Because like they were just racking in the bowl
So don't worry
It's like 40 key of clubs into vermin tide because vermin tide is I mean
I
Liked it when I played it. I thought it was fine
I don't know. Maybe I was mistaken. I thought it was all right. I thought it was all right. Choose me
I thought it was fun
The same thing happened to arc which had a pc
Xbox game
It's really fun. I think it's right. Um
I'm a bit I'm not stuck on what stream snipe games too much just yet. Um
I
I'm struggling to pick
something
I don't know. I really enjoyed fortnite. Sorry. I did. I know I know
For these kids game. I really enjoyed fortnite. It was cute. It was fun. Um, I could get you guys in
I didn't realize we were going against bot. So yeah, I got a bit excited. Okay, the egg is on my face
but
If we put the fortnite
metal path
I just shit
out my head
And I put it on my pc
Because I need me to get the fortnite battle path
Uh
Um a left for dead stream. I haven't actually properly played that game
And it looks really scary and I don't I haven't played it. I played dead island
Feast like a vampire with a woman. Who do you voodoo man up?
But yeah, I never played left for dead. Can we play left for dead together?
Can we play it together?
Don't think I won't do that game up if we can play left for dead together. I'm on it. You're in my team. Okay, you're chatting down the make
But you're not allowed to spill your spaghetti down the make or it'll be forever memorialized
via stream
You never played left for dead. Yeah, you can play it together against each other. You can do 4v4
What I thought the game was about surviving zombies. Why would you attack each other?
Hey, this is my turn
I want to destroy all the zombies in it. No, this is my turn. I want to destroy the zombies
Oh, you get to be the zombie
Okay, I'ma be the zombies and chase the reeflings
I'm sorry
Let me bite your tentacle
Okay, we're definitely doing that because I want to do that
Yep, I tried to play it but I had too much stick to
My brain is gone. Tentacle is too big for you and you take a couple inches off so then it'll fit
I'm like you're I'm like the bar you're like the worst barber in the world
I'm like, I can't fit it. So do me a favor and it's gone and then then you can fit
Is there cross play? I
You know more than me at this point in time. You know more than me
They're releasing another massive horde shooter in september space marine looks good even if you're not into warhammer
Hmm
Hmm curious
For anyone that played back for blood, did it get better or no? We need the foremost tryhard players to own stroney in the girl
Oh, maybe I could get the girls in on stream sniping
And I'll teach them the ways I'll teach them that it's fun
And that they should get used to coming games all the time
Oh, I wouldn't mind that four
four girls
And uh, you're all trying. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Bealer versus
Replace et cetera whoever wants to join
A treat her like a good piece of good Brian
Treat her like a good best of toast butter em up and make her crumb
You're done
Time to go to bed. Sorry. I thank you for the super chat Brian. Don't read that out again. That was a terrible attempt. Okay
Uh vealer versus investors reveal and true
Yonzer contagious. I'm so sorry. I never got big sleep. I go
Like five hours, but I woke up an hour before my alarm, which isn't normal
Because I had a big adrenaline drop when it's really annoying when it does it
I was awake because I can't sleep when once the adrenaline is coursing through your blood. Unfortunately, it's very hard to fall asleep
Because literally I'll be I'm in bed, you know, I'm chilling gimme gimme obviously magnetized to my my heat
and
And then my body just like floods itself with adrenaline and I'm like brah
I was literally just asleep five seconds ago. What was going on? So I had to get up and
This sounds really sad, but I don't I don't mean it to sound sad
But I basically
Slumped against the wall in the hallway and and gimli and vego were comforting me and
I was just waiting for the
Adrenaline to stop
Basically because the medicine takes a hot second to kind of get in the the system
But I was like literally slumped against the wall to the door
The
But don't I don't mean it in a sad way
But if it gets too sad, I'll stop talking about it because I don't want you to worry like I don't mind telling you what's up
but yeah
How's the heart been lately strong? He's been feeling better since the little health scare
Yes, I've not had a heart. I've had I've had a
So that heart flutter and was pretty severe. I have it when I lie
Down from standing up
So I'm needing to be a bit careful
But it's not bad
I think I'm just you know, the stress is get I have is a bit of stress last night. Um, unfortunately
I was editing I was feeling a bit overwhelmed because I tried to like a billion things at once as always
and
We should have held you
Gimli was like doing backflips on me. I'm like gimli, please. I feel so sick right now. Like I feel so ill
and
I was worried I wasn't even gonna be able to get through this stream
But as I said like as soon as I start stream like I just feel like myself again and like it's just fun
And it's a hoot and a holler and you know that goodness
That's what happens to me. Anyway
Hold on. Let me check marshmallow
What are you saying?
I have no idea what the first word of this writer
How about you plugging for a member's ASMR
Replay
That's a terrible idea
You can't believe you had the audacity to even tape something like that
Deal
Replay that's awesome
I have
thalasophobia
But that doesn't mean anything when I'm with you. I love you mommy. Love you too, Reiflin. What's thalasophobia?
Does anyone know what thalasophobia is?
Uh, I have had my heart checked. I'm basically on observations if I have um,
An incident with my heart I'm to go get uh go back to the doctor and then they're gonna do a bit more
I'm post-immigration. Um
Fear of the ocean. Oh
If you're scared, oh, you're scared of liquids you've come to the wrong place because that ain't like nothing on air
You'll be drowning in it when a british person sees a drone drowning in it
Drowning in it. There's like droning it drowning it drowning it
Do you get it? Do you remember it was a squidward meme?
He's not a pirate. I'm glad you get the help
Fucking love or the healthcare. They're so good. Oh, would you need I'm like, oh, I need this. This is what I used
And then you give it to me. I'm all over here. Oh my god. They actually look into my problem
We are up to our tentacles and ink. No, she said the meme
Please laugh
Thank you
Wait, what was that? Wasn't that a gamer convention where the guy goes please clap
What was that? Oh, no
Is it the diablo reveal? I just remember the diablo reveal being an absolute disaster
What you guys don't have uh, you guys don't have phones or something like that and everyone was like, of course
We didn't want a fucking installment is a big microtransaction game get to fuck
That's a politics thing. Oh, was it I thought it was for some reason I associated it with the
Diablo 3 but is this an out of season april fools?
They got annihilated
Don't you guys have phones maybe the single funniest thing ever bro
Let's you like, huh? Why is the reception so bad? And it was like wasn't the first two installments literally pc games
Why are you randomly swapping it to mobile?
And mobile
Lots of people associated it to very unpopular things as a meme so myth transactions probably got a lot
Oh micro transactions got a lot
Fun fact about the game
It was a reskin of an existing
mobile transaction game the guy pitching it
Who said
That was from the chinese company that paid blizzard to let them use their ip
No
It's even worse
It's even worse than what we saw on the surface
I had no idea. I thought they actually made that in full confidence. Oh
Oh
That's even worse
Um, they also made a dead by daylight mobile game. Oh that made it to mobile
Oh
Mobile phones it was an epic failure for sure. I don't know why
They don't usually have monetization as bad as diablo immortal
I'm wondering if blizzard was like bruv if we're gonna sell out to the max
The game is a weird reskin dear god. There's more literally that is I didn't know that I genuinely thought
That blizzard went right mobile games micro transactions. Let's just get rid of this ip and you know burn it into the ground
But it's even worse knowing that they were approached by an outside company and they were like hey, you know your ip
Uh, let's annihilate it together and then blizzard went. Yeah
Yeah
Wow, that's like 10 times worse than I could have suspected
Did you play overcooked? Probably a later day
Almost none of the original blizzard people with passion are left. Anyway. Oh, they're got
Blizzard isn't a husk
Um a husk. I mean, I know overwatch is knees out. Um
Literally overwatch is the only thing from blizzard that I personally
I mean, I've played world of warcraft type thing
um
The starcraft
I'm already overcooked. I'm already tracer
What about widowmaker? I'm already widowmaker
You'll be thinking your fashion. We're at less than 2000 rip pathogen
Also makes identity ryan health news doesn't make us sad or uncomfy mama
It's the thought of something happening to you and at least being honest about it makes it less spooky
Regardless reeflings will always stand by our favorite cephalopod
Ah
Thank you
Anonymous or reeflings. I never know. I just say it says anonymous in the title, but thank you
Okay, I'm glad it doesn't make you so comfy. I can't just shut up if it does like it doesn't bother me to like
as I said
My problems get fixed within 24 hours. So whenever I do complain about something it's like me. It's already gone
you know
um and on reefling and on aning
Um
They make good games that aren't pay to win. That's why I blame blizzard for diablo. Not the actual dev team. Oh
Here's the plot thinking
Uh, don't bottle it up unless it's your armpits, but speaking of bo. I have terrible bo right now
I am pheromone maxing out the ones
who
Hey
The hacker known as
had on reefling
Complain about something random now tomorrow will be fixed. It's okay if it makes you feel better than it's with you
Woo pheromone stinky literally is lost enough tomorrow. Ma I've been so stinky recently and I don't know why I'm like stink maxing right now
I'm vile maxing
I don't know. I think my deodorant maybe I need a new deodorant
Not that I'm wearing any deodorant right now, but maybe I'm just in general
I need a new deodorant to motivate me to put this
Because I'll get a shower and I'll get all clean on use soap and all that
And then instead of like putting deodorant on I just didn't bother and it's like kind of the whole point really
Give me some of that smell
Loose some pheromone scarlet rot maxing
Stress can affect how stinky your sweat is right if that's the case
I'm like stressed out the wazoo and canny think straight
Please put on your deodorant
Can you smell me right now? I'm sorry. Your laziness just makes us want it more
Get roll-ons are amazing. I use roll-ons
I'm just so lazy after my shower
Stress has a lot of negative increase in B. Oh, I did not even know that
So this earwax, wait, did you know that milk is a modified form of sweat? So this earwax, what?
I think earwax is like produced keep your eardrums all lubricated and new dust in them
Don't think you need to rush where she be. I thought she tweeted she's taking the night off. Okay, that's all good
Taking the night off. There's okay
Okay, can anyone of the Paris Bruce smell strong from where they are right now?
Honestly, oh my god. We're already at 1.7 almost. I can't believe it
We're doing it. I'm actually getting up
Someone just leveled up
When you're leveling up someone just leveled up. I saw that
I saw it
I don't know how you leveled up, but don't think I didn't catch that
Oh my god
I can't believe it. It was me
What did you level up? I was doing crafting. Oh, I thought you were doing winery
I'm imagining it dogs because your beel was absolutely weak in I promise you when I go outside
I like shower and I put deodorant on and all that
But on the simple fact that I don't
Go outside
I don't do anything
It's that like there's no point
I may be the most leveled refling the same everyone pointing laugh with the sph on that refill
Shame him for his levels imagine the smell
I won't lie same. Thank you a bit of a bit semblance around here of sanny because like literally
If I don't go outside
What I need to
You have the most game to play exactly
um
I female feature for asmongold. I am not at all
sorry the horror stories I hear about
That um asmongold streams is like there's cockroaches. He's wiping blood on walls
Um, there's rotting food from weeks by god. Oh, oh
The stories I hear
I can I'm in Edinburgh and I can literally smell you in the ocean over the ocean real
Do you have a dead rat to use as a sundial too wait what?
He has rat infestation
What a rat corpse that works as an alarm clock because it smelled when the sun hit it
That has to be he made that has to be made up
Oh
That's oh my that's fellow
I'm that I'm speechless I'm never speechless
What
I
Kind of impressive her nas abroad honestly
That's not clutch. That's not crusty sock ASMR. Are you sure it's not your crusty underwear?
How do you think I'm getting the sound effect?
Look, I told you that I'm feeling a bit stress free these days
You know, you don't know what I'm doing in my undies
You're speechless in subspace too, so I don't know if that's necessarily true
Why am I getting called out? No, I never mentioned subspace at all. You know what you're done, so
That's that. I'm delaying my my blue stream application by one minute because of you
I'm gonna send off myself and get all set up
I'm gonna ask Mercy how she set it up, but um, I'm not charging. I'm just
So
Let's see how the first stream goes if I get too shy then maybe
I don't know
I don't know. I do want intimate experience, but I don't want to charge
I want intimate
Decisions
A whole one minute delay the secret astronomy doesn't have crusty underwear she doesn't wear underwear
Yeah
Sometimes I don't want to stream
But I don't know. I feel like it's a good thing having my bare panini on my chair
Like imagine
Imagine the ink on the chair
Under where
That's why I'm laughing at myself
Some guy literally messed himself to try and get the most xt gained in skill and like a day he turned out to be a bit
Old-school RuneScape players and hygiene go together like milk and monster
That's a
They're like a Pepsi and milk
challenge or something
Underwear is gonna be pure oil extract after a few days
Chairs smeared with untold horrors honestly though the all audio that I did on twitter
May or may not
have been that
I'll need to um
Get my all audio all set up. I really like the method that me did
Where it's like a a list and you can like go seek out the audios. That's like
Sorry, but she's actually
Then my chair's so ripped. I have to sit on a pillow
Okay, but which one's worse your chair or sin
So I have a maincraft chair and it's black and I think you can't see anything because of it
So sin's chair by default looks hell of a lot worse than mine, but I think the reality is mine is worse like
Well, we were talking about it and both of us game bear arsed on it and I'm like we're probably as bad as each other at this point
Um, was it a red bull and milk?
Oh my god 1.6
Biohazard maxing literally means sin on a on a regular sunday afternoon
Whose chair smells worse?
So mine has the extra benefit of
Sweaty feet on it all the time like all the time like right now my sweaty feet are on the chair
So I don't know if that means I get extra points in that category
You sit with your feet against your clam. Yeah. Yeah most of the time
Considerance what sin just admitted about her chair. I think she may have you be wait. What did she say?
Wrong question. Who's smells better?
I say mine probably smells like my ass more and hers smells like her
Vagina's
I can't sorry
Which chairs are more essence not a clue. Oh my god, we're head banging
Oh, yeah, head bang
Good luck on 99 year old Mr. Thank you, Riplyn. We're very very close like very close
Like very close
We're in 1.5 and then it'll be 1.4 and before we know it. There'll be 900
Put pop rocks on your feet again. I'll do it. I think I won't
The lore is great. Thank you
No, put pop rocks on your chair to safety. All right. No, no, no, no, no, no, it wouldn't work like that. It's dry
Oh
Oh my god fans Lee pop. Oh, I said the word uh blue stream
Pop rocks when just to prove the witness
I wouldn't put it inside though just against before anyone's like, oh my god. No
Approve
I
Didn't name drop I didn't mean it. Okay, you can't prove it
You can't prove nothing
Uh, hey, we'll make high baseline. We're here as long as you need us to make sure you take extra care. Love these cutie fish
A little seaweed as well
I'm getting a wee bit sleepy
I don't want to make a cup of tea though because we're literally about to finish
And I don't want to I don't want to pause the grind
So I'm gonna smack myself a week by not smacking myself at all
Because I want to be nice to myself. I'm just
It says 1800 and no
100,000 what 183,000
Eggs pita go that literally is nothing
um
Anyway, this is a point in the stream where clipper say who asked and clips all over the place. What are you on about? What are you smoking?
Sleepy strongy gentificate
A little over 30 minutes, it's the home stretch
Hey clam diving with pop rocks in your mouth
That I wouldn't even
Oh, but can I put pop rocks on you though?
When I when I you know if you were to like suck calamari
Can I put pop rocks on the end of it?
and
Would that work or would that if I would that feel like
A blue stream smoking the seaweed when I don't take it because I have addictive personality
Yes, but it can be painful
Sounded like you're talking from experience. Come on preach to the choir the choir want to know
Now I'm curious pop rocks all spelunky. Oh, no, I don't even want to imagine that
I mean we could find out if you want
I'm not gonna be enthusiastic about it, but I guess you know wherever it goes goes
um
Don't feel free to share with the class
Not gonna lie pop rocks on the tent feel like they would be a weird experience
I mean, it's like a whole different like
tingle ball game at that point
We could just skip the pop rocks and just spelunk a lot. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I like that idea. I like that idea
Speaking from experience pop rocks can burn
Burn why would it burn because it's because of the way it reacts to the
How unique how strange how curious all in one
and
What's the point if you don't try anything
Exactly so get naked
right now
Nice joining everything too much sugar
I suppose sugar is granulated like that green type thing. So it's a bit sharper
If you want the pop rock sensation without the risk of weird
Just have your
Wiefling get a mouth of sparkling water. Oh
Animal animal give her an animal of sparkling water
Oh
I'm not sure about that one chief
Don't put sugar in there
All right, it'll give
Yeast infections. You don't want to make bread from my clam. How dare you?
You wouldn't eat bread created by my clam. I can't believe it
And before anyone's like wait, what is it?
I'll give you a very quick 101
So the clam is a closed-off system in a whammon. There's no exit way except for one. Okay
And the pH is very delicate
And it can create yeast now the first time you've heard yeast you've probably heard it. It's a a thing in bread
It's what makes the dough rise. Okay
So yes in theory you can have yeast cakes made by
scrawny cuttles if you want, okay?
um
But I've been really lucky. I've never had one
But it seems to be like a lottery like you just spawn in with good pey heat pH
Balance or not and I've been super lucky and never had any issues at all like that
But like some poor whammon are like bro. I'm constantly like messed up and I'm like, oh, that's a shame
Yeah
Like the amaranth beer possibly
How much for the scrawny cakes I'll take a dozen
Imagine spawning in without the free bread infinite bread glitch
Have you never wondered why bakeries are 80 owned by women?
No
Yeah, you never you never realized why women are the majority owner of bakeries. I have other business types
Oh my god, it all makes sense now that is fell
Oh dear god
Put that tinfoil hat on right now, okay
I feel like my mind's about to be blown. Not here. I guess
Ten in the vein
I'm about to eat breakfast. We'll be awkward
Let me let me poke in prod. Yeah, I need to get you railed up for what happens later. Okay
Yeah, don't say such things mommy and I'm like, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, keep going. Yeah. Yeah. Tell me how bad I am
Cluthers is free real estate
Shocking behavior
What's happening later? I'm gonna I got my libido back
I'm a I'm a kumar
every day I do it
Ha
Hey, when I'm not stressed every day of
Experience fireworks for the first time
Oh, what will mean in them?
Check for she's just like me for real
Yeah, when I'm not stressed out of every single day
I don't know how many days you do it or how many times kumar are leaving door
I
I'm gonna have to undergo a lobotomy after that education. No, it's not the worst thing that you could ever learn
I'm teasing. I promise you people aren't actually putting their fanny yeast into bread. Okay
I mean if you want me to I'll do it
Sorry, sorry, right hydration check hydration check. Sorry
Sorry, I'm getting I'm getting slightly delirious and I'm getting a bit carried away because I just find it really funny
You know I'll bakery stream get that sourdough starter going depends if you want to save yeast
Women owned bakery is going to be shut down slowly by mummy
I'm
Sub-a-thon prize straw knee bread
so
um
I actually have
A stream coming up to discuss my dough in a thong together
It is a private stream and if I see any leaks, we're not talking about it again because you're all in trouble. Um
But
Um, I can actually make shortbread
And it should last the the distance of like the packaging or whatever
and
so
I couldn't theory make shortbread for everyone
I
Sorry, I'm burping. Um, I don't know if I would have to be
Australia only because I don't know what the border patrol is going to be like because I swear
They're going to break it up and all that shit to investigate if there's something in the shortbread and it's like no
Literally, I'm just leave me alone. I just wanted to make shortbread for a leaflin
That's so bad. I don't like to make shortbread for my own leafling
Bake those graham cracker breaks. No
Yeah, uh, I made shortbread for my dad once and it was absolutely awful
and out of obligation
It was his birthday and I made him shortbread and I like dipped it in chocolate and everything
And I tried it and I was like this is shit and I still gave it to him anyway
Heavily illegal anyways
Probably I'm like looks like I can get it very far
That's incredibly adorable, but I'm not sure if that could be done across the globe
Damn it. We were so close
That's about two levels above the bathwater
His papa's still a lot. Yes
Yes, cuttles
It my dad that was literally here like three weeks ago or two. Oh god. I don't know how long it's been now
Yes, my dad is still bing chining. Does your mom?
Fuck he didn't pop his clogs on the plane
We have to hire smugglers
Just to get the taste of the the scrawny shortbread
You still gave them to them. Oh, you mean did I kill him with it? No, it was just it wasn't very good
It was the first time I ever made him. It just
Wasn't very pleasant, but that's okay
He'd do salt dual ornaments
You can make Christmas tree ornaments out of food
Yes, Johnny dad was visiting mommy in record and finalized his gen two velar model debut stop
Literally nipple hire and it's my dad
What is smaller scrawny or her shortbread
Shortbread is like
Three inches or something like that. I don't know how long shortbread is
I'll fly to Australia to get a load worth it
Cook and stream would be cute though. Okay. I'm down for a cooking stream at some point. I'll need to plan it out
and
I might make a I'll make a cooking stream and and I'll draw my gen mates on the cupcakes or something like that
I'll see what kind of packages like we'll use the pre-made mix. Let's be honest. It's me. Come on. It's me
But I'll make like cupcakes or cookies based on my gen mates and stuff
Because I think that would be really cute
Hey, someone was asking for a thigh cam with three inch object shortbread's a solution pre-made still good
How to get to Hedgeville? It's just a location on the map
If you play for the first time you're in Lumbridge and you need to go north east a little bit and then you'll be to Hedgeville
If you press M it'll open up your map
We're almost under a thousand
I
Was gonna say teach to make tablet, but the cupcake ideas cure. No, baby
I might draw everyone. No strongy. Don't turn us into little bakery goods too late. You're already becoming one
Who's making that noise?
You
How have you got that he's got like a banner and everything you can make emblems in this game
Oh, they're throwing snowballs at each other
Make a bread in the shape of your cake. Oh, yeah
Should I make a cake and then sit on it at the end of the stream?
I'm not saying that she be may or may not have done that if you're not a member of the harem
But am I crazy enough to go through all of that time to bake all these like cupcakes and stuff
And then sit on a cake at the end of the stream. Yes. Yes. I am that crazy
Yes, I think I will do it
It would definitely be a next month stream because this month I'm pretty stacked out the wazoo with everything
I have to like plan everything like hella in advance because I was trying to
If you do an epi higher do sin's mum
Her mum
Honestly, her mum's a hurt in a hole. Thank you tiny spiny
sin's mum
Which would be I think she would be done for it. Um
Oh, no, I think sin's mum has the same problem as my dad where it's legal name and legal address
draft
We still don't know since mum is single by the way. I don't know. It's been in many a year
Times have changed. I don't know
Wait, what was that? It was me laughing out of the blue
Maybe sit on clay and let the shape harden so we have solid proof of that
What happens if I do it and then you can see the wrinkles of my starfish
Oh, oh wait. No, wait, I can't sit on it
Without any cleason
Oh my god, we're about to do it. We're about to go under a thousand wines
I can't freaking believe it my childhood dream
My childhood dream of getting a freaking skill. Okay. No, I don't need to go get a bond
Should I go get the bond now?
I don't know
I don't know. We're like we buy the cape or anything. Oh, sorry. I'm walking away. Sorry. I just got excited
I just really wanted to check out the the woodsmanship the craftsmanship on that. What the table?
If you do sit on it when equals on then you'd have a caked up cake afterwards
Maybe I should sit on it on stream with close and then after stream
I
Keepers nearby, okay, I'll let the reef one
The cooking guilders right by the Grand Exchange that where I get my cake
Next the more needs to be a reef on anything we were gonna see if we can get a cat or more approved
But I don't know if it's gonna get removed
We are here fellow reeflings to experience this moment
We're getting there. We're getting there. Oh my god. There is 900s unbelievable
unbelievable
80,000 wait, how many what 40 more batches and then that's it. We're done. So
I'm not late and I know you're literally right on time. We've just gone below a thousand wine mark
We're doing it. We're actually
factually
Getting it. Mummy's saying in tea. Mummy's saying some teasers are the doughnuts. I'm gonna be so empty
Because I'm doing all like all I'm saying is the cake sitting stream can be a haha youtube thing but then
peeling off the shorts and eating the frosting part will be a
Wait, what? I wouldn't eat my own cake. What?
I
Was it I was gonna take the shorts off and then sit on the cake and take a picture
We're gonna get drained in more way than just money stop you make me sound like fendom or something nonsense like that
Now I um, I hope that the doughnuts on
or
rather fair I need to
Swap a few things on azuras and then check out what she's comfortable with with the price like the rewards for support
And if that's all good
We'll keep it up because then I will work with she be on hers and then mine obviously I get to like fully
I don't really dictate. I just tell the girls like this is what I think is good and we can either say yes or no
Or they can completely make it up on their own. That's up to them as well
and
When the blue streams start we are gonna die if these youtube streams are anything to go by
um
No, no fendom not fendom
Fendom's the other one that she's a dome fish have fins hence fendom. No
Oh my god, we're about to be 800
Oh, this is gonna go by so quick. I can't believe it. Oh my god. I can't believe it. I've never been this far away
from
I can't believe we're doing it
We're doing it 800 already
I'm gonna take it from the berries that is what we're at because I actually don't know what one it is, but yeah
Oh my god, and then you guys need to take me to the grand exchange to get me a bond
And then you guys need to
take me
To the cape and then I'll go buy a cape. I need to take money out as well. Don't don't let me forget
I can't take not to take money out
How much does it cost for an outing and cooking wine? You have extra maybe only 400 more?
Wait real answer
Uh all the reeflings gave me wines and grapes. I didn't even have to
Do anything for it
What's this?
There's a bank inside the gills. It's okay if you forgot
Don't worry mommy will take care of you. Thank you
It's the number that matters, okay
It's inside
My friend oh wait the wines aren't popping so I actually don't know what it is
Uh
Can't wait to follow mommy in another site where she can start tonight. Yes the starting screen said
There's no starting screen. I'm just straight up
You know, you know in a little dj session
Okay, I'm gonna let these wines pop and see what we're at
Uh because I'm not sure what the deal is
It would be a two minute long stream literally the post yeah, right
I'm gonna let these wines pop because I don't know what we're looking at
This is six day the wines are about to pop here pop
Okay, okay a few more a few more a few more batches. Don't don't get in over your head yet. Don't get cocky a few more batches
A russian at the finish line again, and who's gonna stop me?
I like it quick
Mommy getting down to business it's gonna be a fun two minute stream. Thank you. Yes, it is it will be
Now there's gonna be a lot of yapping. I'll see what happens if I get too shy or nervous or whatever
At least east is into it like try some pork leg
I thought about doing a hand cam where I would
Visually instruct you on what to do
Um
But it would be hard to do that and myself so that's not possible it would have to be like a
Follow along on them
I'm happy to chill even without the other stuff
Mommy explaining how to sit in your
Okay, actually, I'm not sure now. Oh, you want to do the west bank for me to 200
Wiki isn't specifying
I can't believe that the runescape wiki how old is this game and the wiki isn't specific
Ink and chill honestly at least wine and dinosaurs before you take our ink and a lot of after gear, please. I'll cry otherwise
I'll cry too
Don't worry. We'll both be crying together but
Those slacks we are for each other
Mommy
I'm gonna go the first two minutes of the steam and then it's the ink clary gonna yap to us probably
I mean I said I was gonna play the coffin at Andy and Lele. I might just play it like on youtube
But um, it looks like a hoot and holler
um
I don't know if I could get another reach of her to come read it with me
Or if it's better experience though, I think the experience might be better though. I don't know
I'm not sure
Plain echo para is that even stream safe with chocolate and vanilla
You arrive just on time as per the script you stop the
Aftercare
The stream version of oh, there's a stream version of neko para. I don't know that
Uh, maybe you know, fuck it. Maybe we should maybe I'll get another v8 come another
The reach of her to come on
With neko para with me. Why not?
I can't believe people think she's really getting a 99. Whoa. Why are you down in me? How are you down in me?
I'm literally 27 xp off like how can there even be any doubters at this point
Steam not stream. Oh, sorry. There's a steam version is safe
Technically if you don't pay you can only play another reach of her to come on
Stop stop stop
No one better be down. How do you thank you for joining us today august 1st. It's not august 1st
August 1st is like she's still pretending this is her game. All right. Is it done? How much are you guys getting paid to be here? No
You're such trolls. You're winding me up
20 oz of dollars you guys you getting paid
No one tell her two feet pics
I'm getting
100 k gp editors not please remove the last three minutes from the
Stop getting paid in shortbread. My window actually says started streaming august 5th
No
My check was late this week by the way, sorry. No, it wasn't
No, it wasn't
He's thinking
Honestly, I'm a paying actor wait
I mean, yeah, I wish I'll support my me
Stunny set this up for male attention. No dignity whatsoever. I literally on the playroom too. Oh, there's a chef hat on the floor
If someone won't
So you admit there is a check that is not paid late. So you're saying there's a check
I get benefits included in my agreement. What you get does dental get covered as well
Am I the only real reefling here you've been fooled. This is all about you all along
Now that I have your attention
No wage no support. Oh my god, they're not gonna walk me over to the cape place because I have no idea
We have dental I didn't get dental
I'm an unpaid actor. I'm working for the experience. My name is a government psyopsis the entire time exactly
I'm just a reefling and training
Oh
Dental I have no teeth. You have a little mess. I'm calling she be from HR
Yeah, good luck with that. She be's in HR. God damn. What do you think's gonna happen?
Are you feeling are you feeling your spread a bit thin at work? Yeah. Well, if you go to she be she's gonna fucking spread you all right
A five dollar gift card was a great bonus for the piece of party. She pays us somewhere else
We're like momentary. Oh
Don't say such things to me
Oh
My god, wait, is that one batch of wine off? What is that?
Is that one batch of wine off is what how much xp is one batch of wine?
Oh my gosh
question mark
How much what how much is one batch of wine?
It's unfermented
Any unfermented
Wayne
It's 200 xp each
Oh my god
Oh my god, we did it my childhood goal
We got our first 99
How
Oh my god, there isn't even like next level because we hit the max level
Oh my god, thank you refling. Thank you for being here and putting up with my rambles
Thank you for running game that gets stream snive
Thank you. We fucking did it
Oh my god, I don't want it. Oh my god. She's so beautiful
Congratulations, you have advanced to cooking level
You just advanced to cooking level your cooking level is 99
Congratulations, you are now a master of cooking. Why not visit the head chef at the cooking guild?
He has something special that is only available to true masters of the cooking skill
My stream pros
Certified trad wife exactly
Oh my gosh, how much money do I need for the cape?
I don't know. Was it like 100k or something?
Are you squiddling me right now?
Are you treating me? You're treating me a hat?
Well done for 99
Oh, thank you bow star. I appreciate it. Oh, you give me a ring?
You give me a marriage ring
Oh, Pearly, thank you for the 20 gifted as well. Congrats to those who caught it. Oh my gosh
Wait, let me put the ring on. There we go
Wait, what? I've actually got a ring
Wait, what? Have I got two diamond rings? I can propose to twice. Thank you Pearly for the gifted more paid actor. You're done
Oh my god math as well. Thank you for the gifted memberships. Oh my gosh
Right, how right wait. No, we need to go to the grand exchange. Okay
Right, hold on. Let me walk. We need to go to the grand exchange
That's a wrap on set. Stop it. Right. We uh, we'll follow the bunny to the grand exchange because we're gonna go get a bond
now
Um, thank you so much bow star. Poorly math
Kalko. Oh my gosh, right. We're totally getting a new emote slot after this one
Bop brigade roll out. Good work. How's the cameraman doing stuff?
And
Right, we'll go get oh, I don't have agility. We're gonna have to go the long way boys. Yeah, I was gonna say I don't have agility
Oh my god, my check finally arrived. Yeah
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Make it rain. Thank you so much
Non-spendy wrote honestly
Who's excited for the stream to go live in a week? It's live right now. Don't listen to them. They're trawling me
Look at their smooth bot like movement
Honestly, thank you pearly. Thank you math 16 18 kalko both are oh my god
We don't we need to put the cape on and then it's done
Beep boop. No, don't beep boop hold on a reflin wants to trade our trade more fellow reeflings joining the hive mind
Amazing stream, thank you
Right, hold on wait. We won't
Hello fellow reefling players
disregard misclick stop
What's up?
Okay, right. How do I buy a bond? Hold on
At tiebreaker alveolar
Thank you for becoming a member. I appreciate it one of us one of us right hold on
I take out all the money and that's how it works right all coins
And then I talk to the exchange clerk and then I type in
B O N D right
Old school bond is what I want right
Momolo, thank you for the 20 gifted as well. Oh my gosh
Walk it hell. Thank you
Uh dad just
Dad just do it
Dad just buy it
Run a reflin chain 13 mil for a bond. Oh, is it gone up in price?
Welcome to the hive mind
Dad dad just yeah, I'll just
Oh, okay. Oh
No, there's no bond for 13 million point nine. Okay
Uh
Bonds were cheap when gold farming was huge, but I need to raise my offer than the minimum right. Let's try that again bond
Up and then sure add five percent on it. No, that's ridiculous. Don't do that add one. No
Add like that two percent increase. Why not?
The offer does that do anything?
I'm pissing this up really badly. Sorry. This is embarrassing. I don't know how to do it
They're a bit rare. Okay. I'm just gonna increase the offer look
Okay, increase it by five percent. Come on 14.5 sold to the highest bidder. Thank you
Right. What the heck is this old school bond untradable what I do
Do
14 days of membership
Redeem one bond for 14 days go for it
Sending redemption request what do you mean? She got scammed out like 700k. It's our
Uh, you've gained 14 days. Please log out before logging into our members world. Okay, that's good
Holy shit
Rack doom. Momolo. Thank you for the gifted membership. What is going on?
Oh my god, right. I'm following the bunny to take me to the the cape. I have 15 million on hand. I'm flexing
Rack doom rack doom. That's how I say rack doom. Thank you for the gifted memberships. Momolo too. Oh my god
Oh
My god guys guys guys your little runescape nerds. What's going on?
Mook ask Ella. Thank you again. Holy crap
Bruh, are you guys all runescape nerds? What's going on? Thank you for all the gifted memberships. You guys are insane
You know, it's gonna run out of people to gift
Is this it we did it open the door, please
Him talk to the head chef
Hello, welcome to the cooking guild. It's always great to have an accomplished chef visit say
Would you be interested in skill cape or cooking? There's uh
Yes, please
Can I buy a skill cape of cooking?
I can't sell you one try talking to me later
Oh
For fuck. It's not registered. I'm a member. Hold on. Hold on. Let me log out. Hold on. Right. Let me come back in. Hold on
Reflings. I'm coming back
Oh my goodness
Thank you again. Everyone who's gifted memberships. You're actually insane
Okay
Okay, let's try that again. Hold on. That was a bit anticlimactic. Let's try. Oh wait. I need to go into a members world
Oh for fuck sake, right? What means a members world?
Oh
Sorry, um
We're just gonna go members
Uh, let's let's be fishing trawlers. Why not in
Yes, uh, stop talking to okay 370
Yes, take me to 370
I'm swapping
To a members world
I don't give a shit about runescape
Oh, thank you for the gift of though
Okay, let's try that again. Okay. Let's not make it anticlimactic. Where is it? Hello. Talk to the head chef
Uh, yes, I would like one skill cape, please
Can I buy a skill cape of cooking from you?
Most certainly by wearing this cape. You'll never burn any food
I will have to ask for this much gold for such a privilege
Sure
Now you can use the title master chef not to be confused with the hit
Oh, wait, it gets you get a hood as well. Oh my god. Welcome to the brotherhood
Oh
My god. Welcome. Wait. How do I mo hold on?
Hold on. We need to mo. Okay. It's outside, right
Look at the drip. Right. Hold on. Let me go outside
How many of you are? Oh
My god, check out the ugly drip. It does not compliment that outfit whatsoever
What we did it. Oh my god. Hold on him with a mo
Hey, give me a spin. Put away motherfucker. Check out that cape. Look at the
Look at the physics. It's non-existent on that cape
Look at that head bang. Oh, yeah. Look at that. Look at that. Wait. What's that a mo?
How are you all flipping pancakes?
Oh my god, I have a special a mo
Oh my gosh, I have a special a mo. Oh sizzling like a sirloin steak in that pan
Oh my gosh. Do it again. Help me again. Hit it in 4k. Got how many of us have scaled up in cooking?
You get a special one for each max scale. That's actually really cool
Only took like 14 collective hours. Are you trolling? It took me a lot longer than that
What's that premiere shield? Is that the oh, yeah premiere shield?
I sell it
And I clap to all the reeflings that came and were able to stream save. Thank you so much. You get kisses
Oh, that love heart doesn't appear. I say yippee. I got my first skill gate
Check it out. Check it out from the back. He hit from the back him from the back. Oh my gosh
Wait, oh my god Avengers looking at him. Yippee, cheer
I don't know. I don't know how I did it. I'm just that skilled i.e
Reeflings gave me all the equipment that I needed and paid for it all. Hi
Oh me. Oh, oh, what are you asking about? Oh, oh me with a skill gate down straight
Uh-huh
What's that something is that one of you something about
Peaky cape gameplay. What's the next one on the list Eddie on we're gonna need a
What's the next one? I I urge you to come closer reefling. I'll tell you what the next one is
I'm gonna get neck neck neck pegging
Hey with a pit away
What is that the famous chef scottles fish you already know it is what you got from me, baby
What's in your inventory?
Are you gonna be beer? Whoa? Why is it so expensive?
I'm not drinking that the ale of the gauze
I don't know if I want to drink that. It's really expensive equip it. Oh, you equip it my apologies
Oh, and then I said right we're gonna just do the one skill cave and then I got a bit distracted and we did another one
Oh look my clients are impatiently waiting. Oh, yeah, you should probably probably get that thingy time to drink 56k wine
Oh my god, can I keep this item? I like the tipsiness. Oh, I would up something's attacking me. What the heck
Are you doing?
Are you inking on me?
Wait, how do you get the throw emote for snow?
I want to throw snow on you. Is it like a an unlock emote explorer trick?
Get an inked on in game
Bottoms up lads. Bottoms up. It'll be on youtube when we're live in a week. Yeah, you done so you done
Thank you so so much again bow star poorly math colker
tiebreaker momolo internet
Bazafile. Whoa, I completely missed that. Holy crap. I'm so sorry. I don't think I said internet bazafile. I'm so sorry
Rack doom momolo and mook askella again for all those gifted congrats to everyone who caught them
Please enjoy the emotes. I know there's a pregnancy one. I'm sorry. I'm not really
Now reeflands remember don't talk to mommy until she's had her coping juice is that what I'm going to call it?
Thankfully the editors will be removing the private party for after oh my god. I'm writing down that audio. Sorry. I'm writing down that audio
Hold on. Let me write it down
Rune skate after party audio after party
priority audio
That'll be on the alt twitter soon tm
Thank you next up is construction so we can have a house party
Bruh, who's gonna be art thing going on here?
Bro, we did it. I can't believe it
Check this out. I'll stand at the door. So I'm not in the way of the other reeflands
Oh my god. I'll have like a tipsy. I can take the snow
Oh my god, fuck you. I don't wait. I had snow in my hand
How do I throw it at you pet? What wait? How do I throw?
Pell fuck you. I'm inking on you. I'm inking on you. Get inked. Get inked. Get inked. You're all getting inked. Get inked. Get inked.
Inking. I'm inking so hard right now
I'm inking so hard right now. Fuck you. Get inked
Fuck you. You're getting too. Didn't know that. You need to make one
Oh my gosh
That's it. You're all getting inked on. Get inked. I need to ink on everyone before we we call it. Okay
Hold on. Let me get who's not being inked on. All right reeflands right line up against this castle if you've not been inked on yet
Line up against the castle. I will ink on you one by one and whoever's spawning in the snow
This dream is over already. I did it. I'm 99. Look. I have the cape and everything
Okay, I don't know who's put oh that's ashes. That's not snow. Okay, hold on right the reeflands are lining up
I'm celebrating against the wall ganked
Wait, hold on. Why did that not work? Oh, it's because they're not equipped to hold on. Hold on. Let me grab some more snow
Hold on. Let me pop. Let me pop that little chat out of the way right right. We'll start left or right ganked
Bang. Oh, why did that miss ganked?
Bang
Wait, what why is that missing? Am I gonna mental?
right ganked
Did I hit that one? I don't know. I don't know if I hit you reefland. Okay, that hit you get ink
Okay, that's four inked if you've been inked you need to get off the wall so I can ink you
Mummy inked on me the firing squad literally
I'm trying to get all the snow
Give me the snow
I've got reeflands to ink. Okay, you're next. No, don't ink me. I'm in can you get inked on
No, don't you have mobile you ink me take that right you get ink
Oh
You get ink
Bonk you're getting
Bonk, please no, I have a slime get inked on
ink
A reeflands this is too much
Gala's on air
Reeflings, thank you. This is too much
Thank you gala's on air. I'm saying it's so bad. Literally a gazillionaire. Oh gazillionaire that is read a lot better
Than how I was saying it. Wait. I'm out of it. I'm out of snow
No, there's snow. I'll take the snow my snow
A gazillionaire. Thank you so much for the freaking 50 gifted membership. She's they're insane
Stroud brain, right? I'm freaking I'm being dumb right who hasn't been inked on
Who hasn't been inked on stay at the wall. She's not being inked on
What hold a gnome ball? What's a gnome ball? Do you even know what that is?
A ball used in gnome ball fair enough. Meanie! Ganked on!
Ganked on
Yee
Oh, do I miss?
No, don't ink back on me. I'm only to ink back on you. Okay, hold on
No, I'm missing. How am I missing your point blank?
Am I missing completely on you? I am
Ganked on
Ink on me mummy with pleasure and glee
Nice aim honestly, it's ridiculous. Did I hit you?
I don't stop. No, you're making it worse. I meant stop you're embarrassing me now
You and I saw oh
Snails trail for everyone don't get inked on. How is everyone hitting him for me?
You're getting snow in my eyes. Okay there. I got you right all the reeflings have been inked on we did it
Yeah
We did it look our beautiful cave
We're all cooking we're all all rinscape nerds together. How adorable
Oh, uh
Congrats to those who call the membership
You're doing it
Inking skill issue honestly
Mummy truly cooked feels good man
No, why is the parrot off my shoulder? Oh, I have to take reefling off my shoulder in order to have the cape on. Okay
Okay, I put the tipsy beer on oh just a little bit tipsy. We are
It's trying to catch in w's and right today. It's amazing. Yeah
We're doing it. We're doing it
Look at that. I can't believe that
Oh, it says a hundred over 99 because it's maxed out
I didn't know that
Let's have a few more emotes. Come on. Let's start him with a e
Oh hit him with the pirouet hit him with the pirouet. Hey
We jumping for joy. We jumping for joy. The cape gives you a one plus boost. Oh
I'm learning
Oh, that was easy. That was so easy yawn. I'm yawning. It was so easy. Oh, yeah
Yeah
Thanks to your family
Flowing a raspberry. I'm panicking. I'm panicking. That was so easy. Oh him with the nobly knees
Show them nobly knees him with uh, uh, uh, oh look at that. I'm turning my feet and
That's so good
You can either combine the hidden cape by using them on each other. So they wear it as a chef. Oh
Hit the gritty literally blown up kiss. Thank you everyone for showing up. Thank you for all the support
Um, but one very happy bean. I think if I wasn't so exhausted, I'd probably be crying very hard right now
I'm not gonna lie. Um
I'm a very exhausted little barbie, but thank you so so much for all the support the kindness the love just everything
This is literally being a childhood dream of mine. I don't even think it's registered
um
That I've done it yet like genuinely don't think it's registered
But uh, don't be surprised if we do some
Questing together for stream sniping. No, don't cry. No, no happy cry happy cry
Our cute and precious master chef. Oh my you're master chef
um
I did it you did it you made me you helped me do it
You didn't make me do it, but you helped me do it. You give me the monies. You give me the wings
You give me everything
Any other childhood goals 100,000 gamer score on xbox. We've got a little bit more to go, but we'll get there
Questing as the first time was really cute. Yeah, we're going to do more quest than at a later date
But we are gonna have a bit of a pause on runescape. Just for a little bit
Eh, glad to know you enjoyed yourself. Thank you
Guys what the
Fuck it's just runescape. It's not that
Ah
Momolo, thank you for the 50 gifted. Oh my god. Wait, does it register the ammo slot right away or does it have to like pull off this?
That isn't seen
Like genuinely whole heart is like
Right, you're all getting barred. Oh, no, it doesn't register
It doesn't register. It must it must take time to process
Oh
My goodness
Just runescape she says
I mean in terms of like the most exciting thing ever. I was just sitting at a bank clicking away
I didn't even knew you could get something for maxing out. They leveled up
Bo Latium as well. Thank you for the gifted membership
Whoa
What is that 170 in the pack, bro? I think we've unlocked two emoteslots. There's no way
There's no way hit them with a spin
Because that's insane
Must void myself of worldly desires. Just runescape. No, no, no. Make sure you're spoiling yourself
Make sure you spoil yourself. You popped your 99 skill to you
skill
Cape cherry. I did. Sorry. That was two C words in a row. Can't believe they expect me to say that
I had to move to a member's world. Unfortunately. Oh, get right. No, no, no, no, no. I'm going offline. I'm going offline
What the fuck I'm going offline brah
Call curve reluctantly saying Odin yakuji
Stop. Okay
Stop. I'm going offline. Okay. No
More. Okay. No more. What the fuck
What? Stop. Serious. Okay. Get supported. Naird. Literally
No more
These are done
Yours are getting paused. He's getting put in the bin
You slow it down. Holy moly. Okay
So what you're doing is just stay full doing more. No, that's called fendom and that's bad
No, that's bad. Okay
Give give give to give to give to literally strontis leaving she hazel not that
Oh my god, that's insane. Thank you so much
Anonymous thank you for the 99 as well. Oh the hundred. There was a hundred. Thank you for the $100 tip as well
Stop right everyone. Stop. I'm going to start fighting on eyelashes in a minute. Okay
And don't think I won't line you all up against the wall again and fart on your eyelashes
Stop giving me money. This is far too much unironically. This is far too much. Stop it
Stop it
These are in trouble
Okay
Serenity is streaming. Okay
I make myself clear serenity is streaming gen 10 confirmed. That's not a threat for
Thank you so much
Silent anonymous and everyone for all the gifted memberships as well. These are crazy
Um, I am going
Take my life. Stop it. Right the beauty lord. Thank you. Stop it. I'm going to redirect into serenity
Okay
As always when it's someone and gen 69 420 honestly
um
I am going to redirect into serenity
Please as always treat um
You know team uh team
Non-vehler members as individuals because I don't know their comfort levels all that jazz not that you guys have ever done anything of that nature
Um, but yes, please uh very kindly be polite and respectful as always
As I know that you can be because you are kind and polite deep down. I know
Um, how am I still green?
I don't that's actually really funny. I'm sorry. That's actually funny
That's actually yep. Take that l
Um
Serenity's marriage in style. She knows what's up. Yeah might have a brand of the count or something
Same
I'm a time traveler from the future gen 74 is crazy. You guys are not ready
I'm not doing more than three gens. I already told you I ain't doing more than three gens. Okay. Hand with the pit away
Um, thank you so so much for everyone who um showed up for the series at any point whether at the start the middle of the end
Um, thank you for all the gifted memberships the love the support. I really appreciate it a little reeflands
I'm gonna go lie down and I'm probably
You know what's gonna happen. I'm gonna lie down. I'm gonna brain rot a little bit
I'm gonna go for a wee nap and then I am going to
um sarson fras
Reflings
I'm gonna start put my angry voice on. This is far too much support
Stop this is far too much support. I'm gonna start getting angry. You in like it when mommy gets angry. Okay
This is far too much support. Thank you
Okay
Okay, um
I um
I found this money in my couch. I love you. Love you too. Thank you boys. Um
I'm probably gonna process it after I've had a bit of a nap or a bit of a sleep. Momma right. I'm getting reeflings
Reflings wrap it up. Stop giving me money. This is outrageous
This is outrageous. Thank you mom alone for the thingy. Please enough
Thank you
Thank
I am incredibly thank you for all the support the love the kindness as always with a streamer like myself
You do not actually have to monetarily hand over yamulas. Okay. Get loved mommy. Oh, I'm feeling the love. I'm I'm jacking off
After that
Thank you gazillionaire stop telling us how to spend our money. Also the super chat was free so you can't get mad. Okay. I'm not mad
But I do I'm aware of how much you gifted. Okay, but I'm not mad
Since it was technically free
Thank you for the extended membership. Wait, no, it's not free. You extended your membership
Don't tell me what to think you extended your membership another payment came out
Okay, thank you so so much. I I'm gonna go. Can I feel like a little love heart above my head?
How did I do that? I don't know
Such a fake gamer honestly. I told you I only do it for male attention
And are you guys gonna be okay? I'm gonna redirect into serenity. Um, I am gonna thank you so so much
plus
Hey, thank you head empty. No thoughts pop up up get support get support get support running away before you can get more gifts
Uh, pretty much. Yeah, I'm trying to tactically run away. Okay. Um, thank you so so much
I will talk to you
Tomorrow at the same time, uh, we're going to do an invest the negation stream and a little bit of education
A bit of rambling more of a that's so experience
um
Okay, thank you so so much. I'm gonna give you a kiss on the lips
Are you squinting me right now? Why do I hear that? Take my money
Oh, right. Okay. Brian's coming through. I was like that better not be a new one. It's it's brian catching up
um
I see you tomorrow
And
We will have lots of fun
Guy noir check this out. Thank you guy noir for the extended membership. Take our love. Thank you jackson's y'all as well
I will take your love. I've received your love. I kiss you back with your love
Um, okay, I'm going before anything else pops up. Goodbye refillings. I love you. Thank you for the support
Please do hold your money and treat yourself with your own money. Okay, because that was a lot. That was big, okay
Uh, uh, okay. Okay. I love you. I'll see you tomorrow. Goofy. Goofy, but please be nice to serenity
Come on